Happy New Year!
Ich bin ein Filesharing-Revolution.
Filesharing-Revolution.
Hier ist nämlich nicht nur der Blumen auf Fritzis, unter anderem auch noch das Chaosradio.
Das ist ja der Monat, in dem wir sonst nie haben, also haben wir jetzt auch noch im Dezember.
Das sind Premiere, das erste Mal Chaos Radio im Dezember.
Wow, weil ansonsten haben wir ja immer Ende Dezember vom Chaos Computer Club unseren Kongress und da können wir ja niemals Radio machen am letzten Mittwoch.
Womit wir jetzt auch der Pflicht auf den Kongress hinzuweisen, zumindest im Ansatz nachgekommen werden. Die Statistiker unter euch Höhrenden können uns dann übrigens gerne Lügen strafen, indem sie uns auf welche Art und Weise auch immer mitteilen, dass wir wohl schon mal ein Chaos Radio im Dezember haben. Wenn ihr uns das mitteilen wollt, dann macht das gefälligst unter Sendungsnummer und Thema. Und bitte eine kleine Zusammenfassung. Schaden kann das ja nie zu wissen, was früher mal war. Worum geht es heute? Ach, ich sag erst mal, wer im Studio ist. Markus Becke-Dahl ist bei uns im Studio. Warum legst du so gesteigten Wert darauf, dass ich deinen Nachnamen sage? Hast du eine Firma, die so heißt?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Wie heißt denn deine Firma?
Netzwerk Neue Medien, kann man sagen. Das ist ein neuer Verein, das ist halb so schlimm.
Ein Netzwerk Neue Medien, der Verein. Der Wettervorsteller sitzt zum x-Male hier, hallo, zum dritten. Und die Musik, die kommt von Katharina. Katharina, sag auch mal was. Ja, hallo, guten Abend, hat sie gesagt. Und jetzt hören wir mal die Musik von Katharina im Hintergrund. Und der Wettervorsteller sagt uns, worum es in der Sendung geht.
Ja, das Thema ist Vergütung im Netz. Wir haben jetzt ja alle Internet und Filesharing und können jetzt da Musik uns kopieren und zu Haufen und irgendwie von einer CD und irgendwie von Filesharing-Börsen. Aber irgendwie die Musiker bekommen davon ja nicht immer was oder ist das auch nicht sichergestellt? Also mit anderen Worten ist das Thema, wie will man Musiker oder auch andere Künstler, die wir über das Internet, über den Computer konsumieren, bezahlen dafür?
Ihr seht es wieder miteinander, obwohl hier Rotlicht ist.
Das ist doch ein absoluter Skandal.
Lernt ihr das denn nie? Ich hab's hundertmal gesagt, ich hab's tausendmal.
Da haben sie sich gelandet hier an den Mikros.
Die sind dazu da zu wissen, dass der Stuart gleich kommt und Getränke nachschenkt. 10-8-10, das ist ja Chaosradio 98 auf Fritz und Vergütung im Netz ist unser Thema. Du hast eben gesagt, Wetterfrosch, wollen wir überhaupt Künstler bezahlen, wollen wir das nicht?
Na an sich schon natürlich.
Gibt es wirklich Leute, die hergehen und sagen, ne, der Künstler kriegt kein Geld dafür, dass er da arbeitet?
Das denke ich nicht, aber die Frage ist ja, ob man das im Internet, diese Musik, die man auf dem Computer hat, man hat ja auch nur Musik auf CD und wenn man dieselbe Musik auf dem Computer hat und man dafür extra bezahlen will oder so, das denke ich mal nicht. Und da ist denke ich mal schon eine Frage, wie man mit Musik eben in der digitalen Form umgeht. Aber jetzt haben wir irgendwie Filesharing und es laufen auch, wir merken, Klagewellen von der Musikindustrie dagegen an, dass die Leute Filesharing benutzen und dann zu Haufen verklagt und es wird verboten, kopiergeschützte Musik und CDs abzuspielen. Und da möchte man sich ja fragen, ob die Leute davon überhaupt eingeschüchtert werden oder ob den Filesharing zurückgeht. Kannst du was dazu sagen, Markus?
Ja, lustig ist eine aktuelle Studie von Allensbach, eigentlich im Konservativen Meinungsforschungsinstitut und die haben festgestellt, dass 26 Prozent der unter 62-Jährigen sich im letzten Jahr illegal Musik aus dem Internet heruntergeladen haben. Und eigentlich nicht verwunderlich. Verwunderlich ist der Anstieg zum letzten Jahr. Letztes Jahr waren es nur 12 Prozent.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo die große Klagewelle und damit auch eine, ich sag mal, Mainstream-Medien-Aufmerksamkeit sich darauf gerichtete, auf das Thema, haben sie alle mal ausprobieren wollen.
Ja, es war eine perfekte Marketingkampagne.
Ja, ausprobieren mal wollen oder überhaupt benutzen, das ist die Frage, die wir euch stellen wollen. Wie geht ihr mit Musik am Computer um? Was habt ihr da für Musik und woher bezieht ihr die überhaupt? Und wie hat sich euer Musikkonsumverhalten verändert mit dem Internet oder überhaupt in den letzten Jahren?
Das fand ich eigentlich das Interessanteste, weil ich bin so genau irgendwie, ich bin ja nun nicht mehr der Jüngste, und ich bin eben noch aufgewachsen mit drei Fernsehprogrammen in schwarz-weiß. Und jetzt ist es 2004. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritzotline. Da sitzt wie immer der Einbeinige, der wartet nur auf eure Anrufe und darauf, eure Anrufe ins Studio durchzustellen. Wie konsumiert ihr Musik? Also wie kommt ihr an Musik heran und wie geht ihr dann mit der Musik um, die ihr habt? 0331 77 97 110 die Fritz Hotline, denn das Chaos Radio lebt auch davon, dass ihr mit uns telefoniert. Chaosradio 98 auf Fritz, Vergütung im Netz, unser Thema 0331 70 97 110. Die Nummer der Fritz-Hotline, unter der ihr Fragen beantworten sollt und vielleicht auch Fragen stellen könnt, falls euch die eine oder andere Frage auf der Seele brennt. Um Vergütung im Netz geht es wie gesagt und die Frage an euch war, wie kommt ihr an eure Musik heran? Kauft ihr noch Platten? Tauscht ihr Platten? Ladet ihr euch Sachen runter? Legal oder illegal? Wenn legal, wo? Wenn illegal, wo? Natürlich nicht, weil das ja illegal ist und wir ja nicht so eine Ordnungswidrigkeit mit den Straftaten aufrufen wollen. Einzig und allein aufrufen wollen wir, dass ihr anruft unter 0331 77 97 110. Wie war ich?
Gut, wunderbar. Der Aufruf zum Anruf.
Vielen Dank, danke schön.
Steve aus Hellersdorf, nach Abend. Ja, schließ los.
Ja, pass auf, also ich bin vom Overhouse eigentlich und beim Overhouse war letztens Tim Renner.
Steve, was ist das Overhouse?
Das Overhouse ist ein großes Gebäude am Rande von Berlin und dort proben derzeit 60 Bands und war auch schon, sag ich mal, multimedial, irgendwie vertreten, Zeitung, Fernsehen, Radio, auch auf Ritz und ja, wie gesagt, Tim Renner war letztens bei uns und der macht ja nun demnächst, sozusagen ab 01.01. seinen neuen Sender Motor FM.
Tim Renner, vielleicht für alle, die ihn nicht wirklich einordnen können, Tim Renner war früher bei Universal Music, da zuständig für den sogenannten Domestic-Bereich, also den Heimatmarkt, also deutsche Musik, ist da gefeuert worden, weil er sehr viele Millionen an die Wand gefahren hat und hat jetzt ein Buch geschrieben über weiß der Geier was, was er aber sehr gut promoted hat, um damit an der Legende zu arbeiten, er wäre freiwillig gegangen von Universal, richtig? Ja, das ist Tim Renner und der macht jetzt einen eigenen Sender auf, weil ihm das Label Motormusic selbst gehört, ne?
Genau. Und der war letztens bei uns und hat dementsprechend sozusagen ein bisschen Publicity gemacht, hat sozusagen nach Bands geschaut, die er da sozusagen mit reinbringen kann, die er da abspielen kann und auch nach Bands geforscht, die sozusagen dort ihre Musik publik stellen und veröffentlichen möchten. Und da hat er halt sozusagen gesagt, dass das Ganze für 99 Cent pro Musikstück irgendwie da zum Mann geht und gewisse Prozentzahlen dann sozusagen zum Musiker gehen. Und im Zusammenhang mit dem Fraunhofer Institut wäre es dann aber auch auf seiner Plattform möglich, die ganzen Sachen dann nach Preiswunsch des Musikers einzustellen.
Wie haben die reagiert, die Bands?
Erstmal relativ, ja, verhalten, sag ich mal. Na ja, Musik im Internet, weiß man ja eigentlich, dass das Ganze, wenn man es bekommen kann, eigentlich auch immer umsonst bekommen kann. Und von daher war erstmal die Akzeptanz der Musiker nicht so rigoros, dass man sagen kann, die waren nun überrascht davon, dass es so eine tolle Möglichkeit gibt, sondern mehr, dass sie da auch mehr über den Tisch gezogen werden als eigentlich möglich.
Hat er dann gesagt, wie viel die Musiker daran verdienen sollen oder wie viel Geld er sich da anstecken kann?
Was die Musiker letztendlich bekommen, können sie selber bestimmen laut Plattform.
Ja, wahrscheinlich müssen die dann irgendwie zwei Euro pro Song nehmen, damit sie irgendwie 40 Cent rausbekommen.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung.
Sag mal, Steve, nutzt du das Internet, um Musik zu bekommen?
Ja.
Kaufst du noch CDs?
Ja, auch.
Ja, auch? Und was bewegt dich dazu? Gibt es noch alles umsonst?
Nicht wirklich, also nicht die Musikrichtung, die ich höre.
Was hörst du, um Himmels willen?
Also ich höre Stoner Rock und die ganzen Platten, die ich haben möchte, die bekomme ich nur aus Amerika und die muss ich immer per Kreditkarte bezahlen.
Was ist denn Stoner Rock?
Stoner Rock ist so ein, naja, sagen wir mal so Kaius, ähnlicher, 70er Jahre, Psychedelic Rock.
Das ist durchaus schwer zu kriegen, ich glaube, so was habe ich noch nie irgendwo gesehen.
Gibt es aber viele Bands in Berlin.
Und die Musik auf deinem Rechner, wo kommt die her?
Die kommen von meinen CDs, die ich habe.
Tatsächlich, du lädst nichts illegal runter?
Na doch, teilweise vielleicht.
Und dann, wenn du das getan hast und dir die Musik gefällt?
Dann überlege ich, ob es sich lohnt, diese CD zu kaufen.
Es ist tatsächlich so, sagst du das jetzt nur, weil es probat ist? Wir können ja auch deinen Namen auspiepen. Nein, nicht so. Ist es wirklich so, dass du dir die Sachen anhörst und dann entscheidest, okay, das lohnt sich, dem Künstler billige ich zu, von mir Geld zu kriegen, dafür, dass er diese Arbeit geleistet und gekauft hat, und das ist original?
Ja, richtig. Also, ich meine, wenn die Qualität gut ist von dem Album und wenn sozusagen das Geld der Qualität wert ist, dann kaufe ich es mir auf jeden Fall, ja klar.
Was ist für dich ein Album wert? Also wie teuer darf es maximal sein?
Na ja, dementsprechend wie aktuell die Preise sind, würde ich sagen, also ungefähr 10 Euro pro Album würde ich maximal ausgehen wollen.
Und dann willst du aber auch eine CD in der Hand haben, oder? Was ich immer so interessant finde, also ich hab mir Anfang des Jahres einen Mac gekauft und da ist iTunes drauf, damit kann ich dann in diesen iTunes Music Store und kann da eben digital Musik kaufen. Und da ist es in der Regel so, dass die Alben 9, 99 Euro kosten komplett. Und da denke ich immer so, ja eigentlich möchte ich aber dann trotzdem nochmal diesen physischen, also einen Datenträger dazu haben, wo wenigstens der Titel der Name des Künstlers drauf gedruckt ist. Also ich finde, mir persönlich ist ein Zehner für die reinen Daten immer noch zu viel.
Das ist richtig, ja also für einen Zehner möchte ich doch bitte mindestens zwei Seiten Booklet haben.
Alles klar. Steve, vielen Dank.
Eine Frage, wie viel MP3s hast du denn so ungefähr?
Schwanzvergleich.
Wie viel MP3s hast du denn so?
28 GB.
Das ist deine Musik, die du zu Hause auf CD hast? Ja.
Mein lieber Steve, schönen Abend noch. Du wirst ja ein paar Tage brauchen, um das durchzuhören.
Ebenfalls.
0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritzotline, wenn ihr mitreden wollt. Und Vergütung im Netz ist unser Thema. Vincent oder Vincent aus Wilmersdorf, wie heißt du?
Ja genau, hier ist Vincent frei.
Vincent, alles klar. Ich hab einen Kollegen, der heißt Vincent, obwohl er sich genauso schreibt wie du, darum hab ich so blöd gefragt.
Ich finde, dass die Musikindustrie selber schuld ist mit diesen ganzen Musikdownloads, weil deren Preise für die CD sind echt langsam krass. Also irgendwie eine Schülerin normalerweise mit einem normalen Einkommen von 20 Euro den Monat kann sich jetzt irgendwie eine CD leisten maximal, also eine CD halt. Und das ist nicht wunderlich, dass dann sich andere Leute oder Personen sich einfach anderen Zugang zu diesen CDs suchen, halt im Internet. Also ich finde, wenn es so weitergeht mit den Preisen, das ist einfach selber schuld. Also kann man das machen.
Liegt es nur an den Preisen oder könntest du dir auch vorstellen, MP3s zu kaufen oder Musik übers Internet halt zu günstigeren Preisen?
Kann ich eigentlich nicht. Insoweit habe ich einen Freund, der sich sehr viel im Netz downloadet und er meint halt, dass die Qualität nicht wirklich vergleichbar mit den CDs von MP3s, sondern wenn man wirklich gute Musik, anspruchsvolle Musik auf einer Anlage hört, dass man schon hört, dass das nicht so eine gute Qualität ist. Und deswegen würden wir uns, wenn wir uns Musik kaufen, keine MP3s kaufen, also was weiß ich, Musik oder sowas, sondern halt schon richtige CDs kaufen wollen. Und dann halt auch irgendwie zu einem angemessenen Preis. Also ja, manche haben überlegt, das jetzt irgendwie die Freizeit zu teilen oder so was, damit man es dann irgendwie besser so hinkriegt.
Wenn du sagst anspruchsvolle Musik, also die kriegst du dann ja auch mal nicht für 13, 99, sondern wenn du, falls du Jazz hörst oder sowas, da bist dann ja ganz schnell jenseits der 20 Euro pro CD.
Nee, ich sag ja, das ist ja das, was ich halt meine mit diesen übertriebenen Preisen. Dass man, also man kann sich, das ist, ja was soll ich sagen, es ist halt einfach viel zu viel.
Was hältst du von solchen Ideen? Ich glaub BMG war's, die wollen das jetzt probieren, zu dieser Zeit verschiedene CD Größen quasi anzubieten, wo du irgendwie die normale herkömmliche, tolle CD mit aufwendigen Booklets und so bekommst, mit etwas höheren Preis und nur für 7 Euro so eine Papphülle, wo dann vielleicht irgendwie mal kurz dein Name draufsteht.
Nee, das war, die Preisstufen waren, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, ein Zehner. Zehner, 13 und 17 glaube ich.
13, 17, ja.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Und das haben sie auch gemacht mit der Zweiraumwohnung. Und haben dafür eine Medienpräsenz gekriegt, die sie auf dem Wege des Anzeigenschaltens schon mal nicht bekommen hätten. Und da gab es dann eben die CD für 9, 99 und das war einfach nur eine Papphülle mit kurz Aufdruck und das war's.
Finde ich an sich nicht so gut, weil ich finde, wenn du irgendwie jetzt in den CD-Schrank reinschaust, dann willst du irgendwie eine CD liegen haben, die auch gut aussieht und wo ein Buch drin ist und sowas. Also ich finde, wenn ich mir schon eine CD kaufe für Geld, dann ist es auch 10€, finde ich schon relativ viel, dann will ich doch auch mal was in der Hand haben, wie so ein Pappteil, was du dann irgendwie nach dreimal anfasst, schon kaputt geht und so.
Aber auch nur wenn du nicht viele CDs hast, ansonsten kriegst du glaube ich die Kratzer. Also ich hab immer gedacht, so meine Fresse ey, müssen diese Dinger eigentlich so dick sein? Weil ich hab eben einige hundert CDs in meinem Besitz. Und das sprengt immer den Rahmen einer kompletten Wand, fand ich.
Ja, naja gut, aber diese Pappdinger sind auch keine Alternative. Ich find an sich die Idee gut, dass man halt so CDs rausbringt, die einfach billiger sind, weil sie eben von der Qualität halt nicht so gut sind. Aber einerseits find ich das auch einfach nicht schön, so ein Pappdingen anzuhalten. Also ich find das lohnt sich nicht. Ich kauf mir gar keine CDs jetzt mehr, weil ich das einfach nicht akzeptiere. So viel Geld dafür auszugeben, wenn ich eine CD haben möchte, dann warte ich bis sie freundlich gekauft und pack mir die auf den Rechner. Oder ich sag halt, ja, Pech gehabt. Also von mir verdient sie kein Geld mehr.
Und um nochmal auf den Computer zu kommen, wie viel Musik hast du denn so als MP3? Das will ich jetzt heute von jedem wissen.
Ja, relativ viel eigentlich. Allerdings ist nicht viel geladen, überhaupt nicht so gut wie. Ja, das sind im Grunde einfach nur CDs, die ich mir mit so einem Konverter halt einfach auf den Rechner gepackt habe. Das sind alles legale Teile da.
Und von Freunden kopierst du dir da auch mal was? Wie bitte? Von Freunden kopierst du von denen auch mal was?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich finde es ist voll okay, wenn man sich von Freunden noch was ausleitet und kopiert und so. Auch von Spielen.
Der Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, aber ganz andere Meinung habe ich kürzlich gehört.
Ja, weil eigentlich was du eigentlich nur machst, ist ja sozusagen eine private Kopie zu erstellen. Und da wurde schon vor 40 oder zig Jahren hier in Deutschland mal beschlossen, dass man sagt, okay, das kann man eigentlich gar nicht kontrollieren, so Privatkopien. Und eigentlich ist es unter Freunden auch voll okay, weil das will man auch gar nicht kontrollieren, weil das so in die Privatsphäre eingreift. Und da hat man so eine Pauschalabgabe auf CDs, auf CD-Rodinge und so eingeführt, die dann an die GEMA aufgeteilt wird. Und was sagt jetzt der Kanzler zu dieser Privatkopie-Geschichte?
Ja, der Kanzler hat kürzlich auf dem Kongress von der D21, das ist so ein großes Industriekonsortium für Deutschland auf dem Weg in Informationsgesellschaft. Und ab deren Jahreskongress hat er halt verkündet, dass Privatkopie Einladung zum Stehlen sei. Und das wäre mit ihm überhaupt nicht zu machen. Als Anwalt müsste das eigentlich besser wissen, weil das lernt man eigentlich im Juraustudium.
Vor allen Dingen als Anwalt der Armen, wie wir ja kürzlich auch erfahren haben.
Ja, ich würde noch sagen kurz, ich glaube, dass ich gehört habe, dass man, wenn man geringer Kopien von CDs erstellt, die man für Freunde verschenkt, die nicht zu verkaufen, ist das doch glaube ich legal, oder?
Genau, das ist das Recht auf Privatkopier, was wir eigentlich seit 40 Jahren knapp schon in diesem Land haben.
Aber das ist doch eigentlich dann irgendwie ein bisschen komisch, dass dann viele CDs jetzt Kopierschutze haben. Also das ist doch, man kann ja jetzt auch die zurückgeben, habe ich dir gehört, dass man die jetzt auf dem, man kann sagen, dass der CD-Schüler die nicht abspielen kann und dann kriegt man das fürs Geld wieder, stimmt das?
Ja, das stimmt.
Weil dann kann man sich da umgründe, also wenn man jetzt ein bisschen illegal wäre, sich einfach kopieren. Ich meine, die kann man ja auch umgehen, die Kopierschütze.
Ja, aber das ist verboten wiederum. Und wenn eine CD mit Kopierschutz ausgeschattet ist, dann darfst du nach der neuen Urheberrechtsgesetzgebung auch keine Privatkopie mehr erstellen an deine Freunde und so weiter.
Noch ein bisschen komische Formulierung im Gesetz.
Ich darf das nicht. Also ich darf den Kopierschutz nicht knacken.
Genau, das ist verboten.
Ich habe aber nummerweise nun ein, es ist tatsächlich so, ich habe ein Gerät zu Hause, das ist ein Sony CD, so ein Doppellaufwerk. Player und Recorder in einem. Und das steht in der Bedienungsleitung, was ich total abgefahren finde. Sollte die CD mit einem Kopierschutz versehen sein, schaltet das Gerät automatisch auf Analogkopie um. Und das darf ich nicht?
Nee, man sieht es ja. Also ich höre zum Beispiel nur Musik über einen Computer und da laufen kopiergeschützte CDs gar nicht. Es steht für mich leider außer Frage, mir Kopiergeschützte CDs zu kaufen.
Andererseits gibt es auch Kopierschutzmaßnahmen, die, okay, mit dem CD-Player ist es nun besonders einfach, wenn der CD-Brenner das automatisch kann, wenn man irgendwie nur die Shift-Taste drückt, wenn man die CD einlegt, dann hält der Kopierschutz nicht und im Gesetz steht, diese Privatkopier ist verboten für Kopiergeschützte CDs, die einen wirksamen Kopierschutz haben.
Ja, dann offensichtlich nicht das, was sich aushebeln lässt, selbst mit Anfängerkenntnissen, sagen wir mal so.
Sogar ohne Erkenntnisse, die man lässt.
Ich bin gespannt auf den ersten, der versucht, da mal einen Prozess durchzuboxen, weil da hat sich auch noch keiner rangetraut, oder? Einfach zu sagen, ich investiere jetzt eine Million, wir können mal sammeln.
Die können sich auch gute Anwälte leisten.
Wir danken für deinen Anruf, Vincent. Und deine gute Nacht noch. Chaosradio 98 ist es, was ihr hört auf Fritz. Vergütung im Netz ist unser Thema. 0331 70 97 110. Das ist die Nummer der Fritz-Hotline. Die Frage an euch lautet, wie konsumiert ihr Musik? Wo holt ihr sie her? Und wie geht ihr damit um, wenn ihr sie habt? Sascha, Frank und Bruno, gedulden Sie sich bitte bis nach den Nachrichten.
Fritz rund um Belsich, dann 91, 9, eine nach halb elf.
Heute Nacht ist es meist stark bewölbt und regnerisch. Die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen plus drei und null Grad. Am Morgen erwarten uns wieder viele Wolken, nicht am Morgen, sondern auch morgen. Außerdem ist es trübe. Es kann ab und zu leicht regnen. Die Temperaturen steigen auf vier bis sechs Grad. Und jetzt gibt es Meldungen mit Gerald Kötterheimlich.
Im Machtkampf in der Ukraine gibt es einen ersten Kompromiss. Regierung und Opposition wollen erst einmal eine Entscheidung des obersten Gerichts abwarten. Außerdem will die Opposition die Regierungsgebäude vorerst nicht mehr blockieren. Im Folterskandal bei der Bundeswehr wird derzeit in zwölf Verdachtsfällen ermittelt. Verteidigungsminister Struck warnte aber vor einem Generalverdacht gegen die Bundeswehr. Es gäbe rund 12.000 Ausbilder. Bis zu 40 von ihnen würden jetzt überprüft. Die Regierungskoalition in Israel ist auseinandergebrochen. Anlass war der Streit um den Staatshaushalt für das kommende Jahr. Die Shinui-Partei hatte Regierungschef Sharon im Parlament die Gefolgschaft verweigert und gegen den Etage stimmt. Ein Blindgänger aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg hat in Berlin bis in den Abend hinein für ein Verkehrschaos gesorgt. Bauarbeiter hatten die britische Bombe am Westhafenkanal gefunden. Die Polizei hatte daraufhin den Stadtrink zwischen Jakob Kaiserplatz und See Straße komplett gesperrt, bis die Bombe entschärft war. Im Fußball-Revapokal spielt Schalke auswärts bei Feyenoord Rotterdam. Und dabei steht's nach 86 Minuten und 42 Sekunden 2-1 für Rotterdam. Der Verkehr auf Ritz keine aktuellen Meldungen zurzeit.
Vielen Dank, Gerald Kötterheinrich. 3 Minuten nach halb 11.
Ritz, neunst euch die 90er.
Ritz, bringt euch die 90er.
Die Fritz-90er-Party on the road. Titel, die ihr liebt.
Und Titel, von dem ihr nicht mal mehr wisst, dass ihr sie kanntet. Die Fritz-90er-Party on the road. Kommenden Samstag ab 22 Uhr im Kurgarten Prenzlau in Prenzlau mit den Fritz-DJs T-Bird und René.
Die Fritz-90er-Party on the road.
Die 90er feiern und im Radio, Meister Musik.
Chaosradio 98 auf Fritz, Vergütung im Netz ist unser Thema. Die Musik, die kommt von Katharina, die mischt die hier gerade so live auf ihrem Laptop, im Studio sind der Wetterfrosch und Markus... Ich kenne meine eigene Schrift nicht. Du hast mir eben gesagt, ich sollte den Nachnamen ganz unbedingt.
Richtig, Aussprüche.
Ja, richtig Aussprüche.
Also Professor Dr. Markus Beckedahl, ist auch für uns seines Zeichens Physiker, Atomphysiker, Rechtsanwalt und Arzt.
0331779110 ist die Nummer der Fritzotliner.
Wir würden ganz gerne mit euch telefonieren, denn der Blumenau Fritz erlebt davon, dass ihr anruft und mit uns sprecht, Fragen stellt oder auch Fragen antwortet. Eingeladen seid ihr auf die Frage zu antworten. Wie konsumiert ihr Musik heute? Heute Hick et Nunk, hier und jetzt, also wo kriegt ihr sie her und wie geht ihr mit der Musik um, wenn ihr sie dann habt? 0331779110 und dran ist der Franz aus Charlottenburg, hallo.
Ja hallo, also erstmal vorab wollte ich Ihnen eine Sache sagen hier. Ihr hattet ja vorhin gefragt wegen Kopierschutz und Trendprogramme. Ich hab gelesen, die Firma Fly Software, die ClonCD und sowas aufgekauft hat, die hat wohl in Gutachten, wie damals diese andere Firma da in Auftrag gegeben und danach ist wohl ihr Programm, was die zurzeit da anbieten, ClonCD, durfte eigentlich nicht verboten werden. Und deshalb bin ich der Meinung, die werden wahrscheinlich das auf den Prozess ankommen lassen. Erstmal nur so viel dazu. Das Weitere ist meine Auffassung, wenn ich mir eine CD kaufe, da mag ich vielleicht jetzt nicht gesetzeskonform sein, aber ich bin der Meinung, dann kann ich damit machen, was ich möchte. Wenn ich das irgendwie oft als Kopie verschenke, solange ich dafür kein Geld nehme und damit handel, bin ich der Meinung, es wird doch okay.
Ja, aber wo kriegt denn der Künstler seine Kohle her?
Na, ich hab's doch gekauft.
Ja, du, einmal. Ja, du hast es einmal gekauft und alle anderen, die es hören wollen, kriegen es von dir geschenkt. Und der Künstler verhungert währenddessen.
Na ja, bloß, es gibt ja noch mehr Leute, die das bestimmt kaufen. Also, es ist ja nicht so, dass ich die gesamte Menschheit abdecke mit einer CD jetzt.
Na, theoretisch schon.
Mit dem Internet ist ja alles möglich. Nutzt du das eigentlich für Filesharing und so?
Ja, teilweise benutze ich Emuil und so. Aber zurzeit eigentlich weniger, weil da das Risiko irgendwo doch ziemlich groß ist. Also, ich lasse mich zwar nicht von dieser komischen Werbung der Musikindustrie da abschrecken, aber irgendwo, da man ja doch liest, der ein oder andere wurde da mal erwischt und da entstehen ja doch horrende Strafen irgendwo. Da geht ja brachial die Musikindustrie vor irgendwo. Da schießen sie mit Kanonen auf Spatzen. Also, die sollten lieber die Rob-Copierer-Szene, aber...
Was ist denn für dich eine Rob-Copy?
Na, für mich ist eine Rob-Copy die Rob-Copierer-Szene ist, wenn jemand damit richtig Kohle macht. Das ist für mich verwerflich. Aber wenn ich das kostenlos irgendwo tausche, das ist doch nicht verwerflich. Es gibt ja richtig Leute, so eine Spinner, die wie dieser Ena Rechtsanwalt so eine Hacker-Szene aufziehen, die da praktisch irgendeinen Server da mieten und dann für teure Geld da so tun, als ob sie da legale Sachen gemacht haben. Das ist für mich verwerflich. Aber nicht wenn jetzt Leute untereinander Musik-CDs tauschen. Das war doch dieses FDP-Welt. Die Namen weiß ich nicht mehr, ich weiß nur, da habe ich mich tierisch über gefreut, dass dieser bekannte Rechtsanwälter drin verwickelt war, der sonst immer Leute mit Abmahnung überzogen hat.
Um es vorweg zu sagen, die Gefahr ist noch nicht so groß, dass man erwischt wird, wenn man bedenkt, dass die Musikindustrie in der ersten Klagewelle 67 Menschen angeklagt hat und jetzt haben sie ihre zweite gestartet mit vielleicht 100. Wenn man mal ausrechnet, dass immer rund 8 bis 10 Millionen Deutsche mindestens Filesharingen machen, kannst du dir mal ausrechnen, wann du irgendwie drankommst.
Ja, absolut. Ich sag mal so, da ich der Meinung bin, wir tendieren ja immer mehr in Überwachung statt. Das geht jetzt ein bisschen ans Thema vorbei.
Ja, das kommt später noch.
Ich sag mal so, die Telekom, die speichert ja auch meine Daten, obwohl ich eigentlich eine Flatrate habe.
Ja, aber das ist die Telekom. Es gibt andere Provider, die machen das nicht.
Welche denn?
Wir machen jetzt keine Werbung, wenn nicht finanziert von denen.
Ich meine, solange die trotzdem irgendwo an diese Daten kommen, ohne Staatsanwalt, oder wie ist das?
Das läuft alles über Staatsanwalt. Im Moment stehen sie noch vor dem Problem, dass sie bei der ersten Klagewelle zum Beispiel Staatsanwaltschaften in Deutschland suchen mussten, die das Ganze unterstützenswert finden. Das von 67 Angeklagten in ganz Deutschland 20 alleine aus Stuttgart kamen. Also, Stuttgart ist ein ganz heißes Pflaster für Filesharing. Da ist es nämlich Wirtschaftskriminalität. Und da ist die Staatsanwaltschaft natürlich sofort drauf und dran, irgendwie alle Wirtschaftskriminalität zu bekämpfen, während hier in Berlin ganz andere Probleme vorherrschen.
Ich sag mal so, die Musikindustrie hat uns Usern jahrelang irgendwo geschröpft. Also die haben damals, als die normale Schallplatte und die normale Single abgelöst wurde durch diese CD, versprochen, die Preise sinken und das passiert nichts. Und ich finde diese Preise, die teilweise da verlangt werden, ist einfach eine Frechheit. Ich meine, ich bin jetzt kein kleiner Schüler, ich bin schon ein erwachsener Mensch, aber trotzdem sind die Preise eine Frechheit.
Von der Musik, die du auf deinem Computer hast, dazu will ich ja immer was wissen. Schätzt du, wie viel hast du davon gekauft und wie viel hast du dir so runtergeladen?
Halb, halb. Halb, halb so?
Und die Musik, die du dir runterlässt und die dir gefällt, kaufst du ja noch später, oder?
Manchmal, also ich sag mal, nicht immer.
Nicht immer?
Okay.
Hättest du da gerne irgendwas, fehlt dir da irgendwas in der Benutzung von Filesharingbörsen?
Na ich sag mal so, wenn diese ganze Konzept, wie die in die Musikindustrie da rangegangen ist, die ist doch total vom Arsch irgendwo. Also die bieten dafür teure Geld irgendwie zu Portale an, denn dann belegen sie das nochmal, dass man die Sachen, die man da runterlädt, höchstens zwei, dreimal kopieren darf und also irgendwo, das ist doch der falsche Ansatz.
Was wäre der richtige Ansatz?
Naja, dass man das praktisch für wenig Geld den Leuten ermöglicht, sagen wir mal, weiss ich, dann bezahl ich halt für eine Flatrate ein bisschen mehr, dann wird da irgendwie so eine GEMA-Gebühr für Flatrate-Kunden gemacht und dann können die Leute sich da sorgen ohne Ende.
Also jeder DSLer zahlt jeden Monat einen Fünfer extra und darf dafür rumschieben, was er will.
Ja, das wär doch mal ein Konzept.
Alles klar, Frank, vielen Dank und gute Nacht.
Und zu dieser ganzen Verfolgung ist ja auch so, je mehr Leute jetzt weitermachen, umso unwahrscheinlicher wird es ja auch, dass der Einzelne rausgepickt wird, also das Kollektiv schützt da an der Stelle.
Vor allen Dingen wird der ganze Justizapparat überlastet und irgendwann sagt er, die deutschen Justiz, wir haben keine Lust mehr, uns damit zu beschäftigen. Das ist total...
Nein, das wird dann eher... Da würde ich dann eher mal denken, dass der Gesetzgeber entsprechende Gesetze erlässt, die das derart unter Strafe stellen, dass wir einfach irgendwie über Denunziantentum uns einen Nebenerwerb leisten können.
Ja, es sieht auch im Moment ganz danach aus, dass ein ganz neuer Industriezweig entsteht, rund um Filme und Musikindustrie. Da gibt es die Gesellschaft zur Verfolgung von Urheberrechtsdelikten. Da sind verschiedenste Ex-Polizisten untergekommen. Auf was? Die arbeiten als private Söldnergruppen und suchen Filesharer. Und dann gibt es dann auch wiederum Anwälte.
Was heißt denn, suchen auch Filesharer? Ich meine, die müssen doch im Grunde nur ein File anbieten. Und sobald sich einer holt, haben die den doch am Sack.
Das Ganze läuft dann so ab. Wie so Polizisten, oder vielleicht sind es auch nur Praktikanten. Die sitzen halt da. Hauptsächlich früher bei Casar. Irgendwann haben sie festgestellt, wenn sie immer erwähnen, dass sie nur Casar durchsuchen und die ganzen Leute zu anderen Suchmaschinen rübergehen, dass es nicht so ganz praktisch ist. Jetzt sagen sie, sie gehen überall rein. Aber sie schauen sich dann an, was die Leute auf den Festplatten freigegeben haben, machen da Ausdrucke. Und mit diesen Ausdrucken gehen sie halt zu Staatsanwaltschaften. Sie gehen zu Staatsanwaltschaften, weil sie brauchen die IP-Nummer. Jetzt haben wir die Daten zu der IP-Nummer.
Moment, aber die IP-Nummer hab ich doch sowieso, weil der saugt sich doch was von meiner Platte.
Ja, aber die IP-Nummer sagt ja noch überhaupt nichts aus. Also du musst erstmal an die Daten rankommen. Die gibt der Provider nicht einfach, der muss die raus. Deswegen muss man den Zwischenweg über die Staatsanwaltschaft machen. Im Endeffekt gibt es da auch Bestrebungen, die Politik so zu nötigen, dass das Ganze geändert wird, dass die Musikindustrie direkt zum Provider gehen kann, ohne den Umweg über die Staatsanwaltschaften, weil das ist einfach nur ein bisschen hinderlich. Eine Staatsanwaltschaft könnte auch sagen, ne, wir haben viel zu viele Probleme, die ganzen Kiffer da draußen und so weiter.
Eigentlich müssten wir so eine Selbstanzeigewelle starten, wie war denn den Kiffern, das machen die ja auch so.
Das gibt's dann bestimmt irgendwann, wenn ihr alle eure Festplatten abgibt, dann geht ihr straffrei aus oder irgendwie sowas Albernes.
Genau, Waffenabgabe.
Gegebenenfalls ganz nett. Ihr merkt schon, Chaosradio 98 ist was ihr hört und Vergütung im Netz ist unser Thema 0331 70 97 110. Das ist die Nummer der Fritzhottler und ihr seid eingeladen hier mit uns zu telefonieren. So wie der Sascha aus Eicher. Hallo Sascha.
Ich wollte eigentlich bloß mal kundtun, dass es mich total ansteckt, dass ich für eine CD 16 Euro bezahlen soll oder aber ich kauf eine leere Hülle mit einer CD drin für 10er und kann da noch nicht mal drüber gestimmen, dass ich sage, wenn ich in das Auto Musik mitnehme, kann ich die mal eben brennen. Weil ich sag mal 16 Euro oder auch 10 Euro ist Geld. Und wenn die CD dann immer durchs Auto geflogen ist, weil rausgenommen oder was auch immer, ist es Schrott. Das finde ich extrem ärgerlich. Ich sag mal, mein Vorredner finde ich ein bisschen doof, was er erzählt, weil wenn ich Musik verschenke, die im Prinzip ja nur für mich gekauft ist, dann verschenke ich ja fremdet das Eigentum, sehe ich ein, ist irgendwo doof. Ist genauso wie, als wenn ich es verkaufe. Ich mein, das ist ein bisschen blöde, seh ich alle ein. Aber warum darf ich als Privater nicht meine CDs kopieren? Ich mein, ich will doch nur einfach das Eigentum, das ich gekauft hab, ein bisschen länger halten. Ich sag immer, ich bin ein Mensch, der auch, wenn er kauft, eher zum Digi-Pack tendiert. Und sagt, schön hab ich was zum Anfassen, ein schönes, äh, weiß ich noch, zwei Extratextreis drauf, noch ein Video, was auch immer, ein DVD mit drin und noch ein schickes Booklet. Find ich schick.
Ja, aber das kriegst du nicht für 16 Euro, oder?
Hm, hängt davon ab. Manchmal sind sie ein bisschen teuer. Ja, aber das ist es mir wert.
Die Musikindustrie argumentiert zum Beispiel so, wenn du dir einen Porsche kaufst und der Porsche geht kaputt, dann kaufst du dir auch einen neuen Porsche und schreibst nicht an die Firma Porsche, dass du halt einen Ersatzteil haben möchtest.
Hm, also da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, ich fahr einen 13 Jahre alten Mercedes und ich würde mir keinen neuen kaufen.
Echt nicht? Ich fahr einen 17 Jahre alten und wenn ich die Kohle hätte, würde ich das machen.
Was heißt, ein V123?
Ein 124er Kombi.
Ich fahr ein 124er Limousin. Ich würde dir nichts von der Welt weggeben.
Stimmt eigentlich, cool genug ist er.
Weil ich muss dir ganz ehrlich sagen, mein Vater hat einen neueren CLK gefahren, das hat er nach zwei Jahren eine neue Benzinpumpe gebracht und einen neuen Boardcomputer.
Und das in einer Fachwerkstatt machen, da kannst du dir gleich einen Kleinwagen kaufen für die Kohle.
Er hat einen Wartungsvertrag, das war sein Glück. Aber selbst dann ist es ja schon mehr Tittels, ein affengeiles Unternehmen, da hast du in der Ringenstraße ist ja die große neue Filiale, so die Konkurrenz zum Salzufer.
Hör mal Sascha, wir schweifen ab.
Hier wird schon immer mal die Perfektion durchgeschafft.
Wie das so ist, ne?
Aber ich sag mal, das ist doch pervers, du kommst bei Mercedes rein und hast den Fixed-Auto-Miet-Schalter gleich mit drin.
Ja klar, die wissen warum.
Das heißt, du kriegst nicht mal mehr einen Ersatzwagen. Nö, du musst dir ein Auto mieten.
Wir müssen hier über CDs reden.
Können wir ja weitermachen, kommt doch aufs selbe raus. Im Endeffekt finde ich, dass die Dinge absolut, dass die immer wieder ankommen, ja, CDs sind teuer, fragst du das warum? Ja, der Kopierschutz ist teuer. Ja, mag ja alles sein, aber wer verdammt nochmal hat eigentlich gesagt, dass ein Musiker Millionen verdienen muss.
Das Schlimme ist, er verdient sie ja gar nicht.
Boi verdient keine Millionen.
Ja, David Bowie, aber guck dir mal so Leute wie Seed an, die verdienen keine Millionen.
Das ist richtig, ich meine, ich bin ein menschlicherer Metal. Es gibt genug Bands, auch gerade hier im Berliner Raum, die seit Jahren Underground sind, wo du die CDs im Prinzip bloß per Kontakt über E-Mail und dann kriegst du eine CD-R mit kopiertem Booklet für einen Fimmer oder so. Klar, gibt es genug. Und logisch, irgendwo der Slogan COBE KILLS MUSIC hat irgendwo sicherlich schon seine Bedeutung. Aber ich denke mal auch das Problem ist nach wie vor, dass die Musikindustrie sich viele Dinge verbaut. Gerade durch so eine Formate wie Popstars oder was.
Ja natürlich, da hört es ja dann auch auf. Also das ist auch die Form von Music, die wir gerne gekillt sehen würden. Jeder, der irgendwie noch einen gewissen Anspruch an Musik hat, der kommt mit diesem ganzen weiß der Geier Kram, also Britney oder wie auch immer, nenn es wie du willst, kommt damit nicht zurecht.
Logisch.
Also das ist eben das Problem, die Musikindustrie sagt uns immer, naja, da können wir keine neuen Talente fördern. Und die neuen Talente, die kommen, heißen Sandy und wissen nicht, dass Hannover die Hauptstadt von Niedersachsen ist. Das meinte ich mit Sandy, also das ist ja dieses Monde. Die habe ich letztens lag ich... Wann war der denn? Ich war ja auf Malle gewesen jetzt. Da habe ich fern gesehen und da haben sie in so einem Boulevard-Magazin diese Sandy von den New Angels, diese Blonde, gefragt. Also da war irgendeine Veranstaltung in Hannover, da haben sie sich vorne hingestellt und gefragt, so in welchem Bundesland liegt eigentlich Hannover? Und das hat, ich glaube, bis auf HP Baxter von Scooter hat das keiner gewusst. Und HP hat auch alle anderen Fragen völlig souverän beantwortet. War sehr schön.
Zu HP Baxter fällt mir eine kleine Anekdote an.
Nur zu.
Ein guter Freund von mir ist auf dieselbe Schule gegangen wie der und hatte den selben Musiklehrer und der schämt sich jetzt für diesen Menschen.
Der Musiklehrer oder der Freund?
Der Musiklehrer schämt sich für HP Baxter.
Das fand ich irgendwie cool.
Der Blonde, der immer so besoffen rüberkommt und sich köstlich amüsiert. Der kommt, der ist amtlich, also Scooter ist amtlich, die dürfen das. Sascha, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Gute Nacht. 0331 77 97 110. Falls ihr mit uns über Automobile, Hannover, worüber reden wir noch heute Abend?
Über Musik und Fußball.
Genau, Fußball und so weiter und so fort.
Und wir wollen wissen von euch, ob ihr es denn voll okay findet, wenn halt die Musikindustrie den Musikern, also Geld einklagt für die Musik, die ihnen ja geklaut wurde und da dann irgendwie Musik im Internet angeboten wird, gab es ja auch schon irgendwie die erste Klagewelle und da hat ein Lehrer 600 MP3s angeboten. 600, also das wäre nur ein Bruchteil von dem, was wir gerade gehört haben, was einige Leute so auf dem Rechner haben als Privatgruppin und hat jetzt dafür 10.000 Euro bezahlt.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber sagt ihr es. 0331 77 97 110. Die Jana aus Lichtenberg hat angerufen, hat eine Frage. Hallo Jana.
Ja, hallo. Und zwar meine Frage ist, wie es ist, wenn man sich Livesets von DJs runterleert, die praktisch dies gar nicht auf CD gibt. Ob das dann auch eine illegale Sache ist in dem Sinne oder?
Das kommt ganz drauf an, was für Musik der DJ verwendet hat. Wenn der DJ zum Beispiel nur freie Musik, Musik unter freien oder offenen Lizenzen, wie den Creative Commons Lizenzen, zusammenmixt, dann ist das vollkommen legal. Wenn der DJ jetzt Scooter mit No Angels mixt und die rechte Inhaber und die Künstler da nicht eingewilligt haben, dann ist das eine illegale Sache leider.
Und wenn man das jetzt vor einem anderen saugt, sage ich mal, dann ist das ja in dem Sinne dann auch illegal?
Also im Moment ist von anderen Leuten Saugen noch nicht illegal. Das Anbieten, da haben sie so eine Kerbe halt reingeschlagen. Das geht halt je nachdem, wo man wohnt. Also Stuttgart geht es nicht. Ansonsten wird halt das Urheberrecht schon wieder geändert. Und ab Herbst nächsten Jahres wird also sowohl das Anbieten als auch das Herunterladen illegal sein.
Gut, an sich muss ich sagen, finde ich das nicht verkehrt, weil man jetzt dafür 10 Euro bezahlt für ein Album und sich das dann auf die Festplatte legen kann. Aber 10 Euro jetzt für ein Album, was ich zugeschickt bekomme mit einer Papphülle, also bin ich nicht von begeistert.
Würdest du nun auch 10 Euro zahlen, wenn du halt Album herunterlädst, dafür bezahlt hast und zum Beispiel keine Kopie für deine Freundin erstellen kannst oder nicht mal einen Mixtape erstellen kannst oder das Album nicht mal auf dein Zweitcomputer rüberkopieren kannst?
Nee, dann würde ich es nicht tun. Aber meistens, sag ich mal, findet man ja einen Weg, um das auch zu entgehen.
Ja, also mp3 ist da immer ganz gut, das.oc-Format ist auch sehr gut. Vorsichtig sollte man sein beim Windows Media Audio System, WMA, weil da ist meistens so eine Kopiersperre eingebaut. Also immer schön darauf aufpassen, mp3 und.oc als Endung, da kann man Geld für geben.
Der iPod spielt ja keinen.oc.
Ja, aber der iPod, wer cool sein will, kann halt irgendwie auf andere Weise nicht cool sein, ne?
Ach so.
Mist.
Und wenn ich dieses Hats jetzt quasi auch weitergebe, dann ist das auch eigentlich in Ordnung. Also weil findet ja noch mal ein reger Tausch statt, sag ich mal.
Ja, also du darfst nur nicht im Internet anbieten.
Das ist ja das Bezarre, du kannst ja privat weitergeben machen, so auf CDs, aber im Internet das sozusagen anzubieten ist ja illegal, obwohl das eigentlich im Prinzip nichts anderes ist. Wenn das jetzt dein Kumpel über das Netz von dir lädt, oder ob du ihm das brennst, das macht ja keinen Unterschied.
Naja, also es ist auch nicht illegal, wenn du in Kanada wohnst, weil in Kanada kann man schon Sachen bereitstellen und auch runterladen. Da hat ein Richter mal erklärt, dass er keinen Bock hat, sich damit zu beschäftigen. Und das macht die Musikindustrie nicht so lustig. Jetzt kann man auch immer sagen, es gibt halt im Urheberrecht so eine Formulierung aus offensichtlich illegalen Quellen und aus Verbrauchersicht kann man halt immer sagen, naja, hätte man aus Kanada sein können.
Na ja, es gibt auch Anbieter, da kannst du Alben runterladen, also MP3s runterladen und zahlst eben nach Volumen. Ja, aber das sind so 1 Cent pro Kilobyte oder pro MB oder so.
Ja, aber das sind so russische Angebote, da sollte man schon vorsichtig sein. Wieso? Die haben sich in Russland geeinigt mit den Künstlern, dass die das anbieten können. Also da ist erstmal schon mal das Wort Russland, sollte man vorsichtig sein. Kann ja keiner so genau überprüfen. Und dann ist halt die Frage, wie es ist, wenn man das Ganze importiert übers Internet, ob das in Deutschland auch recht nicht okay ist.
Und wenn das Geld an die Macht ja schon geht, dann bitte an die GEMA und nicht an die Russischer.
Genau, also die Künstler kriegen da halt so gut wie überhaupt nichts raus. Also deutsche Künstler irgendwie, die man bei All of MP3 oder so weiter kauft für ein Apfel und ein Ei, da haben deutsche Künstler überhaupt nichts von. Da finanziert man halt irgendwelche russischen Geschäftsleute. Geschäftsleute?
Das hab ich heute gehört, der Großvater ein Verbrecher, der Sohn ein Geschäftsmann und der Enkel ein Politiker oder so ähnlich. Alle Fragen beantwortet?
Die Frage, die ich hatte, ist beantwortet.
Hast du noch welche, die wir beantworten können? Wir kennen uns mit allem aus.
Weil diese Live-Sets, sag ich mal, die kann man ja überhaupt gar nicht kaufen. Und wenn die jetzt nicht mehr zur Verfügung gestellt werden können, damit man praktisch untereinander sich die austauschen kann, weil wir jetzt die, sag ich mal, Scooter nun gerade nicht haben wollen, sondern halt dann doch schon spezielle Resets von DJs, die auf gewissen Open Airs mitgeschnitten werden, von wem auch immer, und dann halt freigestellt werden ins Netz zum Ziehen. Und das dann in Zukunft nicht mehr sein soll, das ist ja dann doch schon schade.
Also, Bootlegs ist halt so eine Sache. Das war schon eigentlich immer so geregelt, dass Bootlegs, also Mitschneiden auf Konzerten so weiter, verboten sind. Ein Problem wird zum Beispiel, wenn du Hobby-DJ bist und halt deine eigenen Mixe zusammenstellst und die Fronten irgendwie anbieten möchtest. Das ist eigentlich das Internet, das ideale Vertriebsmedium. Kannst du das auf deine Seite stellen und kannst deinen Freunden irgendwie Link schicken. Hier ist mein neustes Album, hört es euch mal an, gib mir mal einen Kommentar. Aber da wird man komplett illegal, weil man hat die Rechte über die wieder nicht. Und eigentlich ist es schon eine ziemlich komische Sache.
Tschüss, 0331 70 97 110, falls ihr Fragen habt oder sprechen wollt. Wieder Bruno aus Steglitz, hallo Bruno.
Moin.
Wie kommst du an deine Musik?
Ich schneide die im Radio mit, also auf Ritz zum Beispiel, dann lasse ich das Programm laufen nebenbei und schneide es dann danach raus.
Das soll jetzt auch illegal werden, also wenn man die Musikindustrie hört, die haben das schon mit den Politikern irgendwie alles erklärt, dass es alles nicht okay ist.
Moment mal, dass ich meinen Radiorekorder auf REC stelle, ist dann eh.
Er nutzt eine Software. Das ist also analoge Kopien mit einem Tape und so weiter im Radio aufnehmen, so wie wir alle auch groß geworden sind. Also Wetterfrosch wahrscheinlich nicht, aber... Das ist vollkommen okay, das sind analoge Kopien. Aber so mitschneiden ist halt im Moment auch noch okay mit Software, aber wenn es nach Musikindustrie geht, bald nicht mehr. Wird sich zeigen, wie die Politiker darauf reagieren, ob sie es auch illegal machen oder nicht. Nächsten Herbst kommt es raus.
Ja, aber ich zahle doch Gebühren.
Ja, aber für die analogen Kopien.
Na, die Gebühren, du meinst Rundfunkgebühren? Rundfunkgebühren zahlst du nicht, um das Recht zu erwerben, mit dem, was du da hörst, zu tun und zu lassen, was du willst.
Ne, ich schneide es ja nur für mich privat mit.
Das wird kompensiert, so nimmt man ja dadurch, dass du dir halt irgendwie eine Lehrkassette damals noch da so kaufst. Und da sind ja halt so ein paar Stamps drauf, die gehen an die Gimmer und damit ist das ja auch voll okay eigentlich.
Also die Lehrmedienabgabe, also wirklich nicht zu verwechseln mit der Rundfunkgebühr. Die ist für was ganz anderes, nämlich dafür, dass wir uns Mercedes leisten können.
Und wenn sie erhöht wird, kannst du dir auch einen neuen kaufen, ne?
Meinerlei nicht, das bleibt anders hier.
Leider Gottes. Bruno, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Und gute Nacht.
23 Uhr, Chaosradio 98, es ist Blue Moon.
Und Vergütung im Netz ist unser Thema. Zwei Stunden haben wir noch vor uns. 0331 77 97 1 70 ist die Nummer der Fritz-Otline. Ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen und euch zu äußern zu Vergütung im Netz. Wir fragten bislang, wie konsumiert ihr eigentlich heute eure Musik? Wo kriegt ihr sie her und wie geht ihr damit um, wenn ihr sie habt? Und angerufen hat der Bruno.
Bruno?
Hallo? Ja, der andere Bruno Gleichsam.
Genau, aus der Nähe von Hamburg.
Wo kriegst du deine Musik her?
Also ich kauf mir CDs, aber ich tausche auch ziemlich viel mit anderen Leuten, die MP3s haben. Allerdings nur Leute, die ich direkt kenne, also nicht über irgendeine Filesharing-Forst.
Wie machst du das? Ziehst du da mit deinem Laptop umher oder?
Ja, man trifft sich mal so irgendwie eine Runde spielen oder man hat einen gemeinsamen Server stehen irgendwie und die halbe Straße ist vernetzt, da kommt im Forst schon einiges zusammen.
Wie viel so?
Bitte?
Ah ja, der Schwanzvergleich.
Der Schwanzvergleich.
Ich hab eben nochmal die Zehnt, 129 Gigabyte. Das sind so diese ein halbes Gigabyte Weihnachtslieder und was sich alles so ansammelt, was man vielleicht gar nicht hört, aber was man ja mal sammeln kann.
Ruft Steve Jobs an, wir brauchen einen Terabyte-iPhone.
Aber zum Thema Vergütung im Netz, also ich find's ganz interessant. Also ich lerne doch schon viele Musikrichtungen kennen, die ich mir im Laden nie mehr angeguckt hätte. Und um da überhaupt mal reinzuhören, irgendwie um mir aus den eingefahrenen Faden rauszukommen. Man sucht sonst doch immer nach den Bands, die man schon kennt. Und ich hab da schon ein paar neue Sachen kennengelernt, das finde ich auch ganz gut.
Radio und Musikfernsehen ist ja auch nicht so der große Hit, um neue Musik kennenzulernen. Früher war ja eigentlich Radio das Leitmedium, wo neue Musik vorgestellt wurde. Und heutzutage läuft dasselbe überall.
Hier in der Nähe, rund um Hamburg, kann man eigentlich tagsüber kein Radio hören. Das geht nicht.
Ich glaube, du kannst fast nirgendwo in Deutschland tagsüber noch Radio hören, wenn du den Anspruch hast, wirklich neue Musik vorgestellt zu kriegen. Das geht nur noch abends. Aber da finde ich dann wiederum umso besser. Das finde ich ganz interessant, was mich früher immer ein bisschen genervt hat, war, dass tagsüber jeder machen konnte, was er wollte und du hast immer gesagt, du kannst mir doch jetzt nicht Punkrock morgens um 5, das geht doch nicht.
Auch zum Wachwerden immer doch.
Ich bin auch eher so ein Nachtmensch, also abends würde ich da auch ganz gerne rein. Oder hier den Orten in Kanal, da wurde ja in Hamburg so ein bisschen abgeschafft, aber freies Senderkombinat gibt das noch. Da machen halt auch Leute Sendungen, die dann ihre Musikrichtung vorstellen und das ist dann halt ganz interessant, also da lernt man auch viel neue Sachen kennen.
Bietest du auch Musik im Netz an?
Nein, also ich nicht direkt.
Vielleicht meine Bekannten dann, dass die Musik weitergeben, aber das kann ich nicht sagen, aber ich direkt selber nicht. Ich kaufe mir nach wie vor Musik, aber ich unterstütze auch einige Bands direkt. Zum Beispiel habe ich schon ein Jahresabruf für www.davidbohi.com abgeschlossen. Das finde ich auch ganz interessant.
Du unterstützt David Bowie direkt, damit er nicht am Hungertuch nagen muss.
Genau, und dafür bekommt man ja für 100 Euro im Jahr einen E-Mail-Account, Zugriff auf alle möglichen Infos, Bilder, Previews. Oder es steht ja auch so Live-Mitschnitte, die sammeln ja auch das ganze Material zusammen, was irgendwo in irgendwelchen Zeitschritten veröffentlicht wurde. Oder halt auch neue Songs direkt zum Downloaden als MP3. So was ist nicht ganz interessant. Die einstürzenden Neubauten auf ihrer Webseite, die bieten ja auch so was an, dass man Sponsormitglied werden kann. Und man bekommt halt als Gegenleistung auch irgendwie CDs, die sonst nicht im Handel sind.
Ja, die Neubauten haben eigentlich ein ziemlich innovatives Konzept gefahren. Die haben sich gedacht, naja, wir wollen eigentlich eine neue CD machen. Und wir haben keine Lust darauf, irgendwie großes Label und so weiter wie in der Vergangenheit. Und haben mehr oder weniger ein Abosystem oder eine Community aufgebaut, dass halt Leute irgendwie 30 oder 40 Euro dafür zahlten, am Entstehungsprozess des Albums teilzunehmen. Über Chats, über Webcams und so weiter. Oder über gemeinsamen Spaghettiessen über Webcam mit den Neubauten. Und sie haben es tatsächlich hinbekommen, irgendwie ein halbes Jahr lang so schnell wie noch nie ein Album rauszubringen. Aber dann standen sie vor dem Problem, sie wollten auf Tour gehen. Dieses Album wurde halt an die ganzen Club-Teilnehmer irgendwie verschickt. Und als sie auf Tour gehen wollten, stellten sie fest, naja, dieses Album ist halt nirgendswo in den Plattenläden weltweit. Und um auf Tour zu gehen, muss es in den Plattenläden sein vor Ort. Und dann haben sie halt noch eine zweite Platte gemacht, bei einem Label und konnten dann auf Tour gehen. Aber insgesamt ist es eine sehr interessante Entwicklung hin zu mehr Kundenbindung und so weiter.
Kannst du aber auch nur machen, wenn du schon die einstürzenden Neubauten bist. Also wenn jetzt Holger und der Wetterfrosch ihre Band auf diese Weise promoten wollen würden, dann würde keine Sorgen mehr machen. Weil die nicht wissen, wer wir sind.
Naja, aber wenn wir unsere Freunde fragen oder über Orkut, ist dann ein Netz vernetzt.
Über Orkut, genau. Das ist eine sehr schöne Idee.
Das kann klappen. Business-Netzwerke sind ja auch ganz beliebt, um Promotions zu machen. Hast du das Weblog von Johnny Häusler gelesen? Spreeblick.de sei jetzt ein.
Bruno?
Ganz interessant ist es auch mal zu schauen. Es gibt ja einige Webseiten, wo auch unbekannte Künstler Stücke kostenlose versuchen stellen, da mal reinzuhorchen und da mal zu schauen, ob man da was findet, was in eigener Musik geschmackt ist.
Was nimmst du da?
Die Unbekannten haben es tatsächlich schon deutlich schwer, dann halt auch eine weitere Verbreitung zu finden.
Was würdest du dein Name wählen, Bruno? Empfiehle mal eine Adresse, wo man mal gucken kann, wo es freie Musik gibt, die auch von unbekannten Künstlern ist.
Ich weiß schon ein bisschen her, dass ich da mal gesucht habe.
Ich empfiehle immer Flownet, also phlow.net. Da gibt es jede Menge freie Musik, auch vernünftige Rezensionen über diese freie Musik und auch immer ein paar Top 10 und so was. Mein Lieblingsnet-Label ist ideology.de. Da gibt es auch für jeden Geschmack etwas und zwar richtig geiles Zeug, sogar mit Gesang, man glaubt es kaum.
Tonspion wird auch wahr.
Aber Tonspion deckt ja im Wesentlichen das, was schon bekannt ist. Das ist ein Promo-Portal.
Das ist ein Promo-Portal, ja.
Und Flownet eben nicht unbedingt. Bruno, wir danken für deinen Anruf. So, wir waren ja auch dabei. Strafen und so weiter. Martin aus Treptow. Martin? Hey komm, Martin! Das darfst du nicht wahr sein. Martin aus Treptow, ruft bitte nochmal an, weil auf dem Display, das ich hier habe, steht dabei, dass sie dich mal drangekriegt haben.
Oh, jetzt haben sie ihn aber wirklich.
Und jetzt würde uns interessieren, auf welche Weise, was du getan hast und was die Strafe war. Also Martin aus Treptow, bitte, bitte melde dich nochmal. 0331 70 97 110, bis der Martin sich meldet. Da reden wir mal mit Frank aus Spandau.
Ja, ich bin Frank aus Spandau, hallo. Ja, ich bin ja schon mit etwas älteres Semester und ich habe ja noch so die Zeit mitgekriegt, wo die Musik noch von einer scharfen Schaltblätterkappe kam. Und da kam ein Schwerter Sänger her, so Anfang der 80er Jahre, genau. Und da war das noch so. Dann kam von den CD raus und die Plattenfirma haben einem einen riesen Aufriss gemacht, um ihre CDs zu verkaufen und haben gesagt, kauft Platten, kauft eure CDs, die wären so billig wie eure Platten, die mal gewesen sind. Und die mehr Leute CD's kaufen, der ist so billiger, wären auch die Schaltplatten. Das haben sie uns damals erzählt, da war so ein riesen Promotion-Stand auf der Funke-Ausstellung, da war so viel was los damals. Tatsächlich. Und was ist passiert? Nix ist passiert. Die Platten sind genauso teuer wie früher. Und die Herstellungskosten sind nur gesunken. Das Problem ist, dass sich die Margen, die der Konzerne verdreifacht haben mittlerweile, aber das wurde auch nicht in die Günstler zurückgegeben. Die Herstellungskosten von so einer CD waren da bestimmt schweinteuer. Die waren bestimmt 5 Mark oder so und haben die für 30 Mark verkauft.
Ich hab kürzlich auf einer Podiumsdiskussion gesessen. Da saß Peter James, der lange Zeit in Major Labels sich bewegt hat. Und der sagte, dass ein realistischer Preis für einen Song jetzt unter derzeitigen Produktions- und Vertriebsbedingungen 1, 50 Euro wäre.
Richtig, ja. Mal sich das mal hochrechnen, was der Reste noch kostet an Promotion und was dann noch zu offiziell ist für so eine CD.
Das ist ja alles da drin, also es muss auf Künstler aufgebaut werden. Labels bieten da schon eine ganze Menge Aufbauarbeit, vor allen Dingen kleinere Labels. Die kümmern sich um die Künstler, die setzen auf die Künstler und nicht jeder Künstler führt zum Erfolg. Also es ist schon gerechtfertigt, dass die CD-Preise einigermaßen hoch sind. Eine Frage ist halt, wie der Vertrieb gemacht wird, wenn das Internet zur Verfügung steht und man nicht mehr eigentlich viele Kosten für den Vertrieb benötigt.
Erstens das und zweitens sind es zwischen 1, 50 und dann den 20 Euro, die wir mittlerweile noch haben.
Nein, pro Song 1, 50, nicht pro Platte.
Ja gut, lass uns das mal sein. Irgendwie sind es 8 oder 10 Songs drauf von der Platte.
Dann bist du bei 15 Euro.
Ja. Also ich denke mal, da ist noch eine Menge Schwierungen drin.
Also das Problem sind eben, ich behaupte mal, dass von den 1, 50 locker 50 Cent, wenn nicht noch mehr, nur für den Vertrieb draufgehen und Reklame und sonst irgendwie was, wo es eigentlich alles nicht notwendig wäre.
Genau, richtig, das ist genau der Punkt. Weil da sind so Sachen noch drin, die irgendwie nicht notwendig sind, die zu Musik hören. Was interessiert mich, ob die Platte, die ich von Sony gekauft habe, dass die am Portemonnaie einen riesigen Gebäude haben, ein riesen Bürohaus, wo Leute sitzen, im Fenster gucken und passen Millionen, ach, passen mir mehr an, die kostet das.
Und wie ist das so mit kleineren Labels, also von eher unbekannten Fans, die nicht gerade so BMG oder Universal oder so sind?
Merkwürdigerweise kriegt man von denen auch Platten, die billiger sind.
Ja, aber nicht unbedingt, ne?
Nicht unbedingt, natürlich, aber sie haben auch ganz andere Möglichkeiten dann wieder. Es gibt ja auch ganz kleine Labels, die sie hier im Aufbauen sind, wo man wirklich Platten kriegt, die bezahlbar sind.
Ja, aber es gibt auch viele kleine Labels, die ständig kurz vor der Pleite stehen und eigentlich noch mehr machen würden.
Richtig, ja klar, natürlich gibt es das immer, aber wenn man da irgendwie einermaßen zu Gange ist und sich mit dem Markt so ein bisschen auskennt und mit dem Markt auch reagiert, hätte man, die Leute haben ja auch viel zu spät auf die ganze MP3-Sache reagiert, das ist das Problem.
Ja, also da kommen erst jetzt so die ersten Downloadportale nach 5 Jahren nach Napster.
Die haben es einfach verpennt, hätten die schon früher an den Preisen müssen, weil sie sich auch früher darauf eingestellt, wären die Preise für die CDs auch nicht so hoch. Und da könnte man was machen. Und dann wäre auch keiner bereit, nicht ein CD zu brennen, wenn die bloß 10 Euro kosten würden.
Na, das glaub ich nicht.
Doch, wirklich.
Also, naja.
Ich mein, gut, früher haben wir auch CDs kopiert auf der Kassette fürs Auto und so weiter, oder die Platten kopiert. Da hat sich kein Mensch dran gestört.
Doch, doch, die Diskussion, die wir jetzt gerade wieder haben um MP3s und so weiter, die gibt es alle 20 Jahre und eine neue Technik kommt. Also da gab es halt Home Taping is Killing Music vor 20 Jahren.
Es gab tatsächlich eine Kampagne, die ist Home Taping is Killing Music.
Ja, da gibt es halt die Verarschung Home Facking is Killing Prostitution.
Richtig, und was passiert, nichts passiert.
Home Taping is Killing Music. Das ist ja großartig.
Das war 1984 und so weiter.
Genau, die Attackeys, die ja für freien Informationsfluss und so stehen, da gibt es auch einzelne, die drucken schon dieses Emblem nach. Das ist dann halt so ein Totenkopf gewesen und anstatt ein Kopf waren über diesen beiden gekreuzten Knochen ein Tape drauf.
Geil. Es gab ja auch damals wieder, wie die Videos rauskamen, die Videorecorder, die ersten Videotippen und so weiter. Dann haben sie auch versucht, mal einen Kopierschutz einzuführen, dass sich die Leute halt nicht die Filme kopieren können.
Da sind die gerade auch wieder dabei, bei den digitalen Videorecordern.
Und was ist damals passiert? Die hatten dramatische Einbußen in den Vagalog-Kaufs- und Verleihzahlen. Die haben sie ganz fix, klammheimlich wieder rausgeschmissen.
Ja, das ist jetzt dieselbe Frage mit Copierschutz auf CDs. Immer mehr große Labels nehmen die Kopierschüsse wieder raus. A kostet das Pro-CD ein Euro. B kauft die Hälfte der Verbraucher diesen CD nicht mehr. Und C sie setzen jetzt halt darauf, dass Microsoft zum Beispiel in sein nächstes Betriebssystem den Copierschutz sofort einbaut, dass man auf der CD keinen Copierschutz mehr braucht, das in seinem Auto abspielen kann, aber in seinem Computer nicht mehr richtig abspielen kann.
Das ist der nächste Haken wieder. Man muss da ganz realistisch mal sehen, wer sich da Musik runterlädt oder Musik kopiert, wozu macht der das? Der kopiert sich die als sich als Kopie für sein Auto, dass sie die CD nicht zerkratzt, oder um so einen MP3-Player in der Tasche zu haben, und das war's dann auch schon, die meisten Leute. Wenn er da Sachen unterlädt und die Vervielfältigen verkauft, und wenn sie die Leute abwischen, das ist doch mit Recht, muss ich sagen. Aber den Kleinen, wenn dir einer aus dem Kumpel eine CD brennt, die er sich gekauft hat und die weitergibt, mein Gott.
Ja, kleine Fische stinkten auch.
Ja, ein bisschen weit stinkten sie auch.
26% unter 62-Jährigen.
Das hat ja auch gerade was mit den Preisen zu tun. Gerade wenn ich heute die jungen Leute angucke, was die für Taschengelder haben und was die CDs kosten.
Ja, und die Playstation muss ja auch finanziert werden. Die Klingeltöne. Die Klingeltöne, das machen die wenigstens noch.
Unsere Sendung wird sie übrigens auch ab 1 Uhr heute Nacht als Klingelton runterzumachen.
Damit dem machen wir auch gerade mehr Umsätze als mit den Singles.
Frank sei Dank, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Werder Frosch, du wolltest kurz mal bestrafend zusammenfassen. Martin hat noch nicht anrufen. Nein, der hat es nicht wieder geschafft. Martin, ruf nochmal an, der du mit Musik dran gekriegt worden bist.
Ja, Martin, der wurde ja ran gekriegt.
Vielleicht kriegen wir ihn noch im Laufe der Sendung.
Vielleicht kriegen wir ihn auch noch ran. Das wäre natürlich eine Ehre, das wäre nicht nur das Privileg bei der Musikindustrie gekriegt. Ja, wir wollten ja so in dem Komplex der Verfolgung jetzt auch mal so langsamer abschließen. Und wurde schon vorhin gesagt, eigentlich werden einem Rechteinhaber jemanden, der im Internet Musik illegal anbietet, ist ja legal mittlerweile, der muss erst gegen ihn klagen und das Gericht kann dann sozusagen den Internetprovider beauftragen, die Daten zu der IP-Nummer, dieser Adresse im Internet, also wem die zugeordnet ist, welchem Kunden, Name, Adresse, kann nur das Gericht bislang anordnen, diese Daten rauszugeben. Das soll jetzt alles anders werden, und zwar mit einer Novelle von der EU, einer EU-Richtlinie. Und diese EU-Richtlinie soll bis zum Jahr 2006 umgesetzt werden. Und interessanterweise wurde die, Moment Markus, wurde die federführend betreut von Madame Fortout, einer Französin, die reinzufällig das Ehebett teilt mit Herrn Fortout, der Chef von Vivendi Universal ist.
Ja, das ist die EU-Richtlinie zur Durchsetzung geistigen Eigentums, ursprünglich gegen Produktpiraterie und so weiter, also richtig gewerbsmäßige Piraterie ausgelegt. Und dann hat Frau Fortout das im Europaparlament in die Hand genommen. Und seitdem sie beschlossen wurde, ich glaube das war im April diesen Jahres, zwei Jahre Zeit sie umzusetzen, ein deutsches Recht, steht da jetzt auch drin, dass nicht kommerzielle Piraterie irgendwie verfolgt werden kann. Unter anderem durch ein Auskunftsrecht. Das ein Auskunftsrecht bedeutet, wenn Rechteinhaber direkt an den Provider gehen können, ohne den Umweg über Gerichte und sagen können, Hallo, hier IP-Nummer, gib mir Adresse, wir schicken jetzt erstmal eine Abmahnung über 10.000 Euro. Wobei da noch die Problematik natürlich besteht, dass eine IP-Nummer gar nicht irgendwie eine wirkliche IP-Nummer sein kann. Und wenn man Pech hat und irgendjemand jetzt die eigene IP-Nummer gefälscht hat, dann stehen auf einmal die Polizisten vor der Tür, man muss erstmal erklären, nein, ich mache gar kein Filesharing und viele unbescholtene Bürger können da reingezogen werden, abgesehen davon, dass halt Datenschutzrechte komplett ausgeben werden.
An dieser Stelle dann die Frage, die sich viele mit Sicherheit auch stellen an den Radios, wie fälsche ich denn meine IP?
Das haben wir glaube ich bestimmt schon mal geklärt hier im Chaos Radio.
Ich war nicht dabei.
Du warst nicht dabei? Dann können wir auf der Website nochmal nachschauen, chaosradio.ccc.de Und was auch überlegt ist jetzt in der neuen, in der zweiten Korps heißt das, in der zweiten Reformierung des Urheberrechts, ist eine Art Bagatellklausel einzuführen, um die Schulhöfe nicht zu kriminalisieren, wie unsere Südministerin Cyprus ja inständig betont. Und in dieser Bagatellklausel steht, dass nicht bestraft wird, also verboten ist es schon, aber man wird nicht bestraft, werden Urheberrechtsdelikte im geringen Umfang bestätigt.
Ja, was heißt bestraft? Also selbst mit 50 MP3s oder nur 3 MP3s ist man trotzdem den Rechteinhabern ausgesetzt.
Was ist aber in geringer Umfang? Ich glaube, das muss erstmal geklärt werden. Wenn wir hören, dass Leute größtenteils privat von ihren eigenen CDs zusammenkopieren und auf dem Rechner womöglich auch im Netz haben mehrere 30 oder 130 Gigabyte, was ja schon echt immens ist, wo ist da die geringe Menge?
Wahrscheinlich die älteren Herren und wenigen Damen, die sich darum kümmern werden, das festzulegen, die werden dann denken, mehr als 100 Liter braucht man heutzutage nicht. Wenn das dann eher in dieser Kategorie...
Es liegt daran, dass die den ganzen Tag Energy hören.
Ja genau, also es gibt ja auch, die Musikindustrie sagt ja auch teilweise, deren Lobbyisten, naja, man braucht ja gar keine Musik, sich irgendwo runterzuladen. Es gibt ja Musik überall, selbst beim Friseur, ne?
Was sagt die?
Ja, da haben sie einen Cheflobbyisten, der bringt ständig solche Sprüche. Wie heißt der? Ich glaube, das ist Thorsten Braun.
Thorsten Braun, wir sind hinter dir her. Ey, wir haben noch zwei Anrufer. 0331 77 97 160 ist die Nummer der Fritz online. Zum Mitreden hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Der Martin aus Seeburg, der hat zwei Fragen.
Die erste Frage, ihr hattet ja vorhin gesagt, dass das digitale Aufnehmen von Radiosendungen z.B. ja demnächst verboten werden soll oder sein soll.
Ja, also gut möglich, noch nicht endgültig klar.
Ja, aber jetzt ist die Frage, wenn ich jetzt mir sei es Radio oder Internetradio einfach mal per MD-Recorder oder Kassetten-Recorder irgendwie aufnehme, das kann ich ja immer noch auf den Computer ziehen. Und wenn ich das dann drauf hab und dann höre...
Das bleibt legal, das ist der Umweg über die analoge Kopie. Und das ist vollkommen legal.
Du zahlst ja diese Pauschalabgabe von Neversprachen oder diese Lehrkassetten...
Lehrmedienabgabe.
Lehrmedienabgabe dann auf die Minidisc, aber auf deine Festplatte zahlst du das ja nicht.
Ja, aber wenn ich ja wie gesagt dann auf der Festplatte darf, dann brenne ich es mir meinetwegen noch als CD und dann habe ich im Prinzip unendlich viele Kopien, dann ist es trotzdem legal.
Also der Umweg über die analoge Kopie bleibt legal.
Moment, aber dann hast du ja eine digitale Kopie. Und wenn du diese digitale Kopie dann weiterverbreitest, was passiert denn dann?
Das Weiterverbreiten ist eine andere Sache.
Weiterverbreiten willst du ja eigentlich auch gar nicht. Das geht mir ja nur darum, dass ich diese digitale Kopie dann habe.
Aber wenn du für die digitale Kopie sozusagen einen Kopierschutz umgehen musst, wo alle zu tendieren, alle Musikhersteller, dann ist es ja wieder illegal. Und das schon seit irgendwie gut einem Jahr, dass du eben dieses Bizarre hast, dass man zwar kopieren darf privat, aber nicht, wenn man Kopierschutz umgeht.
Was mach ich denn jetzt, wenn ich Lieder suche? Also ich kenn jetzt irgendwelche Lieder, brauchte ich für mein Musikprojekt in der Schule. Und die gibt's einfach nirgendswo auf CD-Platte, was auch immer, zu kaufen. Weil die einfach schon mal uralt sind. Also hatte ich welche von 1910 oder sowas. Ja, die gab's nirgendswo zu kaufen. Weder im Handel noch irgendwo in Internetauktionen oder was auch immer. Ja, was mach ich denn dann? Also ich brauch diese Lieder, ich will die haben, aber ich kann sie halt nicht kaufen.
Ja, also wenn das Lied von 1910 ist und die Aufnahme auch von 1910, dann hast du Glück. Dann darfst du sie dir, wenn du sie findest, sogar herunterladen, weil das Urheberrecht gilt halt nur 50 Jahre.
Nach dem Tod des Autos. Nach dem Tod des Autos.
50 Jahre in Europa, 70 Jahre in den USA. Aber das wollen die auch ändern, hoch auf 70 Jahre Harmonisierung weltweit und so weiter.
Aber selbst dann jetzt muss ja nicht unbedingt so ein altes Lied sein. Also selbst wenn es das einfach nicht gibt, also hatte ich jetzt schon mir Beispiele, wo ich dann einfach gesagt hab, zu einem Kumpel, weil ich selber hab kein DSL, deshalb konnte es runterladen, bei mir ist es nicht so sehr in Frage, ein Kumpel gesagt, hey, hol mir die Dinger doch mal runter. Und dann hatte ich die. Also da hab ich mir dann auch keinen Kopf weiter gemacht, weil ich mir dann gesagt hab, naja, die Musikindustrie hätte durch mich dann eh kein Geld machen können.
Also es ist ein ziemlich großes Problem, dass halt eine ganze Menge Kulturgüter einfach so in den Archiven der Rechteinhaber verschwinden. Also ältere Lieder, für die es halt gerade scheinbar keinen Markt gibt, aber die halt bei den Fans auf einmal durch Filesharing-Börsen auftauchen. Also ein Markt, der überhaupt gar nicht da ist eigentlich, aber schon da ist. Und das wär halt auch eine große Chance für die Rechteinhaber, irgendwie dieses Songs wieder online zu stellen. Es gibt ja immer irgendwelche Fans von irgendwas, die irgendwas suchen. Und im CD-Laden oder im Saturn findest du das schon gar nicht. Also da bleibt noch zu hoffen, dass da noch viel mehr passiert. Dass es auch irgendwann mal legaler Angebote gibt, die akzeptabel sind für Verbraucher, wo man an all diese sogenannten alten Bettkataloge reinkommt.
Aber im Moment ist es im Prinzip noch illegal.
Gute Nacht Martin. So, dann haben wir noch Murat aus Schöneberg. Hallo. Du hast auch noch eine Frage.
Ja, und zwar habe ich erstmal eine Frage, und zwar, als ich das richtig verstanden habe, können zurzeit, kann sozusagen die Polizei erstmal nur über den Rechtsweg zu einem nach Hause kommen sozusagen.
Ja, die Polizei, die kommt eigentlich auch nicht so freiwillig nach Hause. Die kommt dann auch nur, wenn der Rechteinhaber, meistens so die Labels oder sonst irgendwie, ja dich verklagen. Und dann kommt die Polizei eigentlich nur als Vollstreckungsorgan mit, weil die Rechteinhaber ja nicht persönlich bei dir zu Hause alleine auftauchen dürfen.
Aber um erstmal eine Adresse zu bekommen, müssen die Rechteinhaber vor Gericht gehen, ja. Na, die schauen sich die Filesharing-Börsen an und gucken, was da so getauscht wird. Und wenn du Sachen anbietest oder runterlebst, dann müssen diese Computer sich ja auch untereinander adressieren. Und das machen sie über diese IP-Adresse. Und ja, dann merken sie sich halt, okay, zu der und der Uhrzeit hat der und der Nutzer mit dem Pseudonym, mit dem wir jetzt nichts anfangen können. Also unter dieser Nummer, an dem Tag was angeboten. Und der hat seine Nummer von einem bestimmten Internetprovider. Das lässt sich gleich herausfinden, von welchem das ist. Und dann fragen sie, dann ziehen sie halt vor Gericht und bitten halt über den Richter, den Internetprovider, die Daten, sofern sie denn vorhanden sind, und nicht jeder Internetprovider speichert das auch. Also danach könnte man sich vielleicht auch seinen Internetprovider künftig auswählen. Muss dann der Internetprovider die Daten rausrücken, sofern sie vorliegen, ja.
Also an die IP selbst erst mal herankommen, das ist doch auch schon mal ein Problem, oder?
Nö, das ist ganz trivial eigentlich, wenn du ein bisschen verstehst, wie ein Computer funktioniert. Also ohne IP-Adresse können diese Computer nicht miteinander kommunizieren.
Achso, aber in so einem normalen Netzwerk eigentlich, was schon relativ gut ausgebaut ist, sag ich mal, sind ja Milliarden von Usern. Oder Millionen, keine Ahnung, ich kann mich nicht übertreiben.
Das ist so mehr eine Lotterie, ne?
Das ist das Rechtsanwaltsbüro in Stuttgart, von dem du sprachtest, was für die Musikindustrie Nutzer rausgesucht hat in Filesharing-Börsen.
Also da kann, wahrscheinlich gibt es auch irgendwann so einen Ausbildungsberuf so, Filesharing Nutzer Sucher oder so.
Mal gucken, wen sie finden und den Erstbesten schnappen sie sich dann.
Ja genau, also man guckt halt nach möglichst vielen, um die Streukurte ziemlich hoch zu erhöhen, weil nicht jeder Richter und jede Staatsanwaltschaft spielt da mit. Außerdem steht man doch vor dem Problem, man muss ja erstmal rausfinden, wer das ist. Selbst wenn die IP-Nummer in einer Adresse zugeordnet werden kann, ist es ja für die Musikindustrie nicht immer ganz praktisch, jeden zu verklagen, weil a, man könnte die Nichte von Angela Merkel sein, das wäre ganz schrecklich für politisches Lobbying oder ein 14-jähriges krebskrankes Kind macht sich nicht gut in den Medien und so weiter. Also da in den USA sieht man schon, wie das Ganze abläuft. Die suchen sich bewusst auch sogenannte Loser-Typen aus, die garantiert nicht vor Gericht gehen und für ihre Rechte kämpfen. Also echt Menschen, die man einschüchtern kann mit einer 10.000-Euro-Strafe, wo man sagt, entweder du akzeptierst jetzt 10.000 Euro oder du gehst vor Gericht und klagst um dein Recht und dann musst du vielleicht das Doppelte bezahlen.
Das hört sich ja fast so an, als wenn man schon Leute dafür bezahlt, dass sie so tun, als wenn sie feif für die Wende, dass man sie vor Gericht irgendwie anzeigen kann, dass es so in die Zeitung kommt und dass dann andere irgendwie Angst bekommen.
Das ist eigentlich die Strategie der Musikindustrie zu sagen, hey Leute, wir finden das ist total doof und scheiße und deswegen verklagen wir jetzt zunächst mal, dass wir alle verklagen, obwohl es eben eher so ein Lotteriespiel ist und man da kaum den Jackpot knacken kann. Also relativ unwahrscheinlich ist, dass man als Einzelner rankommt. Wollen sie jetzt so die Leute verschrecken und wenn es sein muss auch das ganze Internet leer klagen? Ist da so das Bild, was sie einem zu vermitteln wollen und stattdessen dann ihre Musik nur noch als mit diesen Downloadportalen für ein Euro oder ein Euro 50er Stück verkaufen?
Mit Kopierschutz.
Mit Kopierschutz, was du dann noch nicht mal dir auf dein iPod oder so ziehen kannst?
Noch was, und zwar, also das weiß ich jetzt schon besser Bescheid, und zwar, gibt es irgendwie so eine Methode oder so was, dass die beim Provider nachgucken, Top 10 der Traffic, von der Traffic ja die User, und die dann anklagen oder so, geht so was?
Technisch ja, aber ich wage es zu bezeichnen, dass Provider diese Daten rausgeben darf.
Also Provider leben ja davon. Also wer braucht einen DSL-Anschluss, wenn nicht irgendwie für...
Das ist ja echt die Frage.
Die Online würden sich selbst ins Bein schießen, wenn sie jetzt so was machen würden, weil dann würden halt alle zu woanders hingehen oder halt sagen, naja, für meine Mail checken reicht doch ISDN.
Murat, das wollen sie ja.
Keine Panik.
Mach weiter so.
Ist klar. Es ist immer wieder eine Güterabwägung, hören wir aufschließlich diese wunderbare Musik, die Katharina im Hintergrund live zusammenmischt oder reden wir und wie es sich für ordentliche Narzisten gehört, reden wir. Nichts für ungut, alle die diese Musik hätten hören wollen.
Wenn Fritz in Paltensee, dann 102, 6.
Eineinhalb, äh, Mittag 12, aber...
Ich lerne es nie.
In der Nacht ist es meist stark bewölbt und regnerisch, die Tiefstrate liegen zwischen 3 und 0 Grad, also plus 3 und 0 Grad, auch morgen erwarten uns wieder viele Wolken, außerdem ist es trübe. Es kann ab und zu leicht regnen und die Temperaturen steigen auf 4 bis 6 Grad. Und jetzt steigen die Meldungen mit Gerald Kötter-Heinrich.
Im Machtkampf in der Ukraine gibt es einen ersten Kompromiss. Regierung und Opposition wollen erst einmal eine Entscheidung des obersten Gerichts abwarten. Außerdem will die Opposition die Regierungsgebäude vorherst nicht mehr blockieren. Im Folterskandal bei der Bundeswehr wird derzeit in 12 Verdachtsfällen ermittelt. Verteidigungsminister Struck warnte aber vor einem Generalverdacht gegen die Bundeswehr. Es gebe rund 12.000 Ausbilder, bis zu 40 von ihnen würden jetzt überprüft. Die Regierungskoalition in Israel ist auseinandergebrochen. Anders war der Streit um den Staatshaushalt für das kommende Jahr. Die Shinui-Partei hatte Regierungschef Sharon im Parlament die Gefolgschaft verweigert und gegen den Etat gestimmt. Bei einem Wechsel des Mobilfunknetzbetreibers darf die Mitnahme der Handynummer nicht mehr als 29, 95 Euro kosten. Diese Obergrenze hat jetzt die Regulierungsbehörde für Post- und Telekommunikation festgelegt. Hintergrund sind die hohen Preise, die zwei Mobilfunkdienstleister von ihren Kunden verlangt haben. Sport im Fußball-Uefa-Pokal hat Schalke auswärts bei Feyenoord Rotterdam 1 zu 2 verloren. Was die Schalke aber nicht mehr so stören wird, weil die sind ja glaube ich schon weiter. Egal, der Verkehr auf Ritz A24 Berlin Richtung Pritzwalk. Die A24 ist zwischen Neuropin und Herzsprung bis ungefähr 0 Uhr 30 noch gesperrt, weil da ein LKW geborgen und abtransportiert werden muss. Ansonsten keine aktuelle Meldung.
Vier Minuten nach halb zwölf gleich.
Event, das. Umgangssprachlich für kulturelles Ereignis.
Und Fritz hat davon gleich einen ganzen Kalender. Der Fritz-Eventskalender gewinnt im Advent jeden Tag Tickets für alle. Für ein Event, Konzerte von den Toten Hosen, Rammstein, Mia, Green Day, The Roots, Gala, Silbermond und den Beastie Boys. Der Fritz-Eventskalender.
Noch bis zum 24.
Dezember. Und im Radio.
Chaos Radio 98, wir marschieren stramm auf die 100 zu. Da gibt's was. So alt. Genau, das ist echt, das ist Wahnsinn. Da gibt's da eine Party dann dazu bestimmt oder was? Da gibt's was ganz besonderes, es fällt aus, es geht direkt weiter mit der 101.
Das ist doch mal abgefahren.
Wir machen die 100 B.
99 B, das ist geil.
Ja, aber vor dem Chaos Radio 100 gibt's ja noch so ein Kongress.
Genau.
Zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr, 3 Tage CCC, volle Kanne.
Furchtbar. Das ist das, wo ich nie sein kann, weil meine Mutter an Weihnachten Geburtstag hat. Ich grundsätzlich bei meinen Eltern dann eine Weile.
Ja, aber das ist doch ein Grund zu sagen, du musst doch mal im Kongress und 2 Tage, 2 Tage.
Möchtest du nicht, weil mein Vater dir erzählt, deine Eltern wohnen doch bestimmt dann auch noch da, wo du herkommst. Ja, dann bist du Weihnachten doch da unten, dann kommst du mal zu meinen Eltern und sagst, der kann dich echt nicht.
Ich mach das auch seit ein paar Jahren so, dass ich immer so bei meiner Familie in Niedersachsen bin und dann am ersten Weihnachtsfeiertag dann gleich nach Berlin, dann hat man aus sofortem Grund, nämlich der 21. Chaos Communication Conference.
Sie hat am zweiten Weihnachtsfeiertag Geburtstag.
Ah, also halt am nächsten Tag morgens oder nachts.
Und was erwartet mich da beim Kongress?
Ganz viele tolle Vorträge und Workshops und Nerds. Und in den Vorträgen natürlich nicht, es gibt ja 3000 Hacker bestimmt, die wiederkommen werden. Da liegt es in dem... Da gibt es unten so einen großen Raum.
Wenn man immun ist, kann man Hacker hinlegen.
Ansonsten empfiehlt es sich doch eher, sich in den Workshop-Bereichen aufzuhalten, wo alle möglichen Themen des Clubs abgegrast werden. Ob Datenschutz, wie funktionieren Computer von Leinen des fortgeschrittenen Bastel-Workshops. Es gibt einen eigenen Hexen, also die weiblichen Teilnehmerinnen unter den Hacker, einen eigenen Hexen-Track. Das ist einfach volle Kanne.
Man kann auch hinkommen, wenn man kein Hacker ist und sich nur für die Themen interessiert.
Und Hacker werden.
Hacker und solche, die es werden wollen.
Bei den Hexen war ich mal da, und zwar habe ich da den letzten Tag mitgekriegt. Da war ich bei einem Hexen, das ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her. Das hat direkt zur Folge gehabt, dass ich mir einen Nintendo 64 mit Super Mario Kart gekauft habe.
Gott, was haben wir da vorne wieder?
Die haben das auf so einer großen Leine vorgespielt.
Wie jedes Jahr, auch dieses Jahr, der Chaos Communication Congress. Zwischen den Jahren, wo genau?
Alexander Platz in der Kongresshalle, 27. bis 29. Dezember, www.ccc.de.
Gibt es Blinkenlites dazu? Gibt es dazu Blinkenlites?
Gute Frage, ich weiß es nicht. Bestimmt entleihen.
Entleihen die Leute, die das machen.
Das wäre geil, ne? Faltplatte, kennst du Faltplatte?
Ne. Echt nicht? Was?
Das gibt es so, musst du mal, www.faltplatte.de, mach mal. Das ist Plattenbau, ja, als so Pappmodell zum Zusammenfalten. Total abgefahren. Und da gibt es nämlich auch die Kongresshalle und das Haus des Lehrers als Pappmodell. Und da kann man sich ja immer Blinkenlites selber basteln für zu Hause. Machen wir weiter mit unserem Thema. Das Thema heißt eigentlich Vergütung im Netz. Wir haben jetzt sehr lange darüber gesprochen, auf welche Art und Weise wir bzw. ihr Höhrenden euch Musik besorgt und wie ihr dann mit der Musik umgeht. Aber es gibt ja noch viel mehr zu berichten und zu erzählen. Einen kleinen Ausflug wollten wir noch machen, bevor wir hier mit unserem eigentlichen Musikthema weitermachen. Und zwar einen Ausflug zu Robert aus Stahnsdorf. Robert, bist du noch da? Dir geht es ums Fernsehen.
Ja, es ist ja so, dass man, wenn man eine TV-Karte hat, gut und gerne Filesharing oder wie der Begriff war, auch über TV machen kann. Dass man einfach die Videos rauszieht und dann einfach den Audioton rausfiltert.
Klar doch. Kannst du einfach den Audioausgang deines Fernsehers an deinen Computer anschließen oder deinen Kassettenrecorder oder so?
Ja, also meistens wäre ein Digital-Receiver mit angeschlossen und dass man dann einfach über die TV-Karte das dann auch digital aufnimmt. Also, dass es so digital übertragen wird.
Ja, aber genauso wenig erlaubt.
Ist auch nicht erlaubt.
Zumindest die Weitergabe ist nicht erlaubt.
Eigentlich muss man Frau Zyper hier anrufen, unsere Justizministerin, und sagen, was die nicht alle schlaustellen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die das weiß. Das ist ja gerade das Problem.
Fernsehen verhält sich prinzipiell genauso wie Radio. Also genauso wenig wie du im Radio was mitschneidend und einfach so verteilen darfst, darfst du Fernsehen mitschneidend und einfach so verteilen.
Also, ja, das ist eigentlich der gleiche Fall.
Aber solange du es so zeigst, analog mitschneidest und dann Freunde kopierst, dann geht das ja, aber diese Unterscheidung hatten wir jetzt ja schon oft.
Ja, aber du darfst es nicht öffentlich vorführen. Als Lehrer, der eine Sendung im Fernsehen mitschneidet, der darf eigentlich nicht irgendwie 30 Leute in seiner Klasse diesen Film vorführen.
Das eigentlich total absurd ist, weil alle sagen, ja mehr Medien-Einsatz in den Schulen und chillen und toll und wir gucken auch so viele Filme. Und an der Schule, wo mein Brudermann Praktikum gemacht hat, da ist wirklich passiert, dass eine Schülerin, die irgendwie deren Vater irgendwas mit dem Film zu tun hatte, den sie geguckt haben, wirklich gesagt hat, hey Papi, sag dir mal.
Echt? Also mit dem...
Die ist ja wohl hoffentlich in den nächsten Mülleimer gesteckt worden, oder?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Mein Bruder war auch nicht so lange, das hat er nicht.
Kommen wir wieder zu, Robert. So was erfreulicherem hoffentlich.
Also es bleibt ja immer noch digital, ne?
Also wenn man es jetzt durch diesen neuen Fernsehen, durch diesen neuen Fernsehformat... Ja, dadurch bleibt es ja eigentlich digital. Verboten.
Weil wir jetzt zwischen Analog-
und Digital-Unterschieden haben einfach.
Genau. Die Frage, um die sich alles dreht, ist sozusagen die digitale Privatkopie. Und was soll ein der anders sein als der Analogen? Fragen wir uns.
Ja, also ich selbst bin noch eigentlich CD-Sammler, aber ich bin längst dazu übergegangen, also im Internet hauptsächlich meine CDs zu bestellen, weil es einfach billiger ist. Weil ich kann im Handel, bezahle ich für eine CD 15 bis 20 Euro. Also ich sammle Soundtracks und da ist einfach ein gutes Forum, Ebay oder so. Und da kriegt man die für einen Euro bis 10 Euro, bezahle ich auch manchmal dabei. Und die konvertiere ich mir dann einfach und dann ziehe ich mir die auf die Festbata als MP3.
Ja, ein guter Weg, Geld zu sparen, ist auch immer direkt bei den Künstlern oder den kleinen Labels zu kaufen, wenn sie Angebote haben. Immer mehr Labels bieten das an, haben ihre eigenen Shops auf ihrer Internetseite und da weiß man dann, das Geld kommt eigentlich da an, wo es verwendet wird, um neue Musik zu produzieren.
Also über diese sekundären Angebote wie Foren und eBay jetzt auch beispielsweise, unterstützt man die ja nicht wirklich, wenn man es jetzt darauf abgesehen hat. Es ist bloß einfach billiger, darauf achtet man ja schon zum größten Teil einfach. Und mit mp3s hab ich auch bis jetzt nie so große Erfahrungen gemacht. Ich hab mir eigentlich nie irgendwie so groß was runtergeladen, aber ich kenn haufenweise Leute, da gibt es die verrücktesten Geschichten, dass die bis 1, 5 Terabyte als mp3s allein sich runtergeladen haben.
Die Samen sind nur noch, die hören das gar nicht mehr.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich hab schon, und das bringt ja Beruf natürlich auch mit sich, ich hab viele hundert CDs in meinem Besitz, also irgendwas zwischen 6 und 800 Centes. Die hab ich alle gerippt, das hat aber witzig lange gedauert. Ich hab wirklich wochenlang nur da gesessen, ferngesehen, ripp, ripp, ripp, ripp, ripp. Und hab die jetzt alle auf Festplatte. Das sind so irgendwas so 6000, 6000, 7000 einzelne Titel. Unglaublich viel Schrott natürlich auch dabei.
Wie viel Arbeit?
Holger Klein, was ist deine Haftanschrift so?
Ladungsanschrift, sehr schön. Das 25, etwas über 25 müssten das sein.
Das ist ja aber ganz schlecht komprimiert, oder?
Ja, 128. Die meisten sind 128.
Das ist schuld.
Ja, ich weiß.
Hänselt mich. Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich hab schon darauf geachtet, dass die guten Sachen, also die Jazz-Sachen mindestens 192 sind.
Wenn nicht sogar 256. Jazz mach ich sogar schon mal 256. Das ist an alle den Tipp, wenn ihr das in 5 Jahren nicht nochmal machen wollt, wie der Holger das dann machen muss, wenn es endlich die guten Soundanlagen gibt für zu Hause, dann macht ihr das mit 256.
Carvids eure Rips von den CDs.
Also bei Punk-Schrammelmusik kann man auch 64 machen.
Ja, nee, das tut mir auch sehr leid, vor allen Dingen für mich. Der arme Musiker erstmal. Es fällt mir schon schwer, all diese Musik zu hören. Das sind gerade mal ein paar tausend. Wie ist das, wenn es ein paar zehntausend sind? Also das macht man doch dann gar nicht mehr.
Ja, wenn man mehrere tausend Dateien hat und das dann einfach nur noch sammelt. Es gibt ja einfach den Unterschied zwischen wirklichen CD-Sammlern und einfach die Sammler, die wirklich die mp3s in Massen sammeln und die nie mal gehört haben.
Das sind die, die früher am Strand Steinchen aufgehoben haben, ne?
Ja, genau.
Hast du das getan, Markus?
Ja, also ich verstehe es auch nicht, warum es immer auf Unverständlich stößt, wenn ich dann sage, ich sammle CDs noch gern und ich finde es einfach richtig, wenn man das CDs kauft, statt sich runterzuladen. Also es wird dann immer ganz unterschiedlich betrachtet.
Du meintest, sorry, wenn ich dich unterbreche, du meintest gerade, du kaufst dir Musik oder CDs auf Ebay. Eine vollkommen noch nicht geklärte Frage ist, was ist, wenn ich mir MP3s oder WMA-Files in einem kommerziellen Musikportal kaufe, sagen wir für 1, 50 Euro, kann ich die dann immer noch bei Ebay verkaufen? Also das ist noch vollkommen ungeklärt. Das wird in der Zukunft wahrscheinlich noch sehr spannend werden, wo die Leute sich überlegen, naja, kauf ich mir jetzt ein CD, die kann ich weiter verkaufen, verschenken, verleihen usw. Oder erwerbe ich mir kommerzielle Musik aus dem Internet über MusicLoad oder sonst irgendwie, wo Kopierschutz eingebaut ist, wo ich also höchstens 2-3 Mal kopieren darf, wo ich die nicht weiter verkaufen darf, wenn die Musik schlecht wird oder man sie gar nicht mehr mag. Und wo ich ein Problem habe, wenn ich zum Beispiel Windows ansetze und ein Virus zerstört meine ganze Festplatte, bekomme ich die ganzen Lieder wieder? Oder was ist, wenn ich irgendwie 10.000 Lieder auf meinem iPod mit mir rumsteppe, die ich alle irgendwie gekauft habe?
Und was machst du, wenn du ein iPod verlierst?
Ja, oder da geht Wasser drüber. Also tut mir dann Apple irgendwie 10.000 Lieder wieder auf meinen neuen iPod drauf.
Interessant ist ja, wenn du ein iPod verlierst, jemand ihn findet und die Songs dann in eine Filesharing-Börse stellt und jeder Song, der dann geteckt ist, ist von Markus Becke da gekauft. Dann bist du dran.
Deswegen hab ich kein iPod, ne?
Ich dachte, weil du ihn eben nicht leisten kannst.
Robert? Ja, das wollte ich noch mal sagen. Das Vorteil ist einfach, wenn man CDs sammelt und sie sich natürlich auch alle als MP3 üben kann, dass man dann einfach die auch immer portabel, wenn man jetzt, wie ich jetzt, eine Jukebox hab, die man dann immer mitnehmen kann und immer seine ganze CD-Sammlung mit tragen kann in so einem kleinen Ding, das ist einfach praktisch. Ja, und in dem Fall, wo sie mal kaputt geht und die Dateien verloren gehen, kann man sie ja immer noch neu kopieren.
Insofern da kein Kopierschutz drauf ist. Ich hab zuletzt mal mit unserer Frau Justizministerin Zybris kurz darüber geredet und fragte sie, was mach ich denn mit kopiergeschützten CDs, die ich mir gerne kaufen würde. Aber auf dem Keim meiner Computer sind die abspielbar. Und ihre Antwort darauf war nur, kaufen sie sich einen CD-Player.
Ich benutze hauptsächlich als Programm Powerlame und Audiograbber.
Obwohl der Audiograbber, hab ich gehört, der ist auch nicht ganz legal.
Darf man das hier nennen?
Der Hinsicht?
Also bitte benutzt nicht Audiograbber.
Da haben wir auch immer nichts gesagt. Das ist halt einfach sehr praktisch mit den MP3s.
Frau Zypries, die ist ja auch Justizminister und nicht MP3-Minister. Die muss sowas nicht wissen.
Wollte ich nur mal sagen.
Die muss ganz andere Dinge wissen.
Vielleicht sollte sie sich mal mit der gesellschaftlichen Realität auseinandersetzen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, dazu gehört er dem Bundestag an, um sich nicht mit der gesellschaftlichen Realität auseinandersetzen zu müssen.
Da kriegt er auch sehr viel Schmerzensgeld jeden Monat für.
Nicht genug, nicht genug mein Bester. 0331 771 Mehr Geld oder mehr Schmerzen? 0331 771, so ist übrigens die Nummer, die ihr anrufen müsst. Wenn ihr hier mitsprechen wollt im Chaosradio 98, Vergütung im Netz ist unser Thema. Und wir wollen, ich glaube seit fast einer Stunde über Kopierschutz reden, oder?
Haben wir dazu vielleicht jemanden in der Leitung zu?
Nee, haben wir leider nicht, das hat nicht so ganz geklappt.
Der Andre war da noch dran, aber auch jetzt nicht mehr.
Warte mal, der Andre, doch, Moment mal. Andre?
Hallo, ja ich bin noch da.
Der Andre ist noch da, hallo Andre. Sag mal was zum Thema Kopierschutz, da wollten wir eigentlich noch drüber reden heute hier.
Ja, also ich wollte sagen, dass über diesen Kopierschutz bei einigen neuen CDs ist das richtig scheiße, weil man kauft dich ein neues Album und dann einfach man legt ein, hat einen alten CD-Player und dann läuft die CD nicht richtig. Ja, also da sitzt man dann so davor, freut sich so schön, ja, jetzt hab ich endlich mir eine neue CD gekauft und dann so, scheiße.
Da kannst du ja einen neuen CD-Player kaufen, oder?
Ja, das sagt jedenfalls die Bundesjustizministerin. Du musst dein Radio ausmachen, sonst haben wir eine Rückkopplung.
Oh, ja, oder auch am Computer, denn wenn man das nochmal über WinApp abspielen will, dann sieht die Songs, ja, schöne Länge und dann startet der einfach nicht. Da sitzt man ja immer so was von frustriert davor, also, ich finde, das ist gekloppt, dieser extremen Kopierschutz.
Das würde ich einfach nicht kaufen.
Das wird ja auch alles noch schlimmer.
Ich hab kein Internet, wie soll ich mir an so was reinkommen? Ich würde mir das eh kaufen, weil, wenn ich mir das immer nur schwarz brenne, wo sollen denn die Firmen, die mir jetzt diese Lieder, die die Lieder zusammenfetzen und so, an ihr echt kommen?
Und der Künstler erst, der das ganze singen muss und machen muss.
Na gut, meine Favoriten sind jetzt so Enemy Openings und Endings. Da haben die Künstler jetzt nicht so direkt was davon. Wer?
Wer?
Enemys, diese japanischen Zeichentrickserie. Und dann hab ich noch eine Frage.
Aber da müssen ja auch irgendwelche Leute malen und so.
Nee, die Sache, wenn ein Lehrer jetzt sich irgendwas mitschneidet auf dem Fernsehen, was denn der Klasse zeigt?
Da macht er sich strafbar?
Ja, das ist eine öffentliche Vorführung. Ja, Schule ist ein öffentlicher Raum.
Es gibt aber eigentlich eine Ausnahmeklausel dafür, dass sozusagen die schulische Veranstaltung sozusagen erlaubt ist im Sinne des Paragraphen 53. Aber das ist halt die Frage, ob sozusagen der Unterricht eine schulische Veranstaltung ist oder ob es eine Veranstaltung der Schule am Abend oder so gilt. Also es ist halt auch ziemlich sehr darum gestritten.
Achso, nee, weil unser Lehrer, unser Physiklehrer quält und der schon seit ein paar Wochen wird so wirklich grau sein.
Noch so ein Film und sie landen vor Gericht.
Also kannst du ja mal probieren.
Das lesen wir dann wieder in der Bildzeitung, falls wir die lesen, falls wir uns in die Nierung hören.
Ich hab jetzt meine Kohlenhydrate im Mund, Moment. Und zwar die Musikindustrie, also ihre Bestrebungen, die wir jetzt herausgestellt haben, sind ja, dass wir einmal alle Leute abschrecken vom Internet und dass sie nie wieder Filesharing machen, weil da könnte man ja verklagt werden, obwohl das einer von Millionen, also die Wahrscheinlichkeit kann sich da jeder selbst ausrechnen, ziemlich unwahrscheinlich ist, dass man da als Einzelner dran kommt. Und wenn das ganze Internet dann sozusagen keiner mehr darin Filesharing macht, ganz illegal, oder diejenigen, die es machen, schnell weggeklagt werden, dann kann die Musikindustrie endlich wieder auf ihrem legalen und herkömmlichen Wege Musik verkaufen, und zwar diese kopiergeschützten Songs. Und dafür stellen sie sich DRM vor. Und das Problem an diesem DRM, Digital Rights Management, Digitale Rechteverwaltung oder Digital Restrictions Management, auch gerne übersetzt, weil es eigentlich eher eine Restruktionsverwaltung ist, was man alles mit der Musik, die man sich kauft und runterlädt, nicht machen darf, das soll ja damit verwaltet werden, damit das richtig funktioniert und nicht die Leute wieder anfangen, die MP3s, die sie abspielen, auch wieder aufzunehmen mit einem anderen Computer daneben oder im Zweifelsfall mit einem Mikrofon vom Lautsprecher. Na gut, das geht eigentlich immer noch. Aber so lange sie sozusagen digital die Sachen noch weiterhin aufnehmen oder kopieren wollen, es gibt ja immer irgendwelche Wege, so einen Kopierschutz doch zu umlisten, auch wenn es manchmal etwas schwieriger wird. Umlisten?
Das müssen wir Frau Zufried sagen, dass sie das mit ins Gesetz aufnimmt, dass das umlisten, dass das böse ist.
Da das alles natürlich mit so einem Computer, der ja alles kann, auch immer wieder möglich ist und dass ja nur einer, mal zu sagen, so einen Kopierschutz im Gen braucht und das dann wieder in Filesharing-Revolution stellen kann, deswegen soll das vom Computer her kontrolliert werden und dazu, weil das sozusagen die Kulturindustrie gerne möchte und sozusagen den Herstellern von Computer Hardware versprochen haben, dass es einen ganz großen Markt gibt, denn alle Computer den Leuten verbieten können, bestimmte Musik oder Werke überhaupt abzuspielen oder zu kopieren. Zumindest sozusagen die Kontrolle über die Dateien, die ich auf einem Computer hab, mir zu nehmen. Um das möglich zu machen, soll ein spezieller Chip in jeden Computer eingebaut werden. So ein richtiges Stück Hardware, was von diesem Firmenkonsortium, da sind alle drin, also Microsoft, Intel, AMD, alle, und soll dieser TCP-Achip heißt da, trusted computing, vertrauensvolles Computing, ich weiß es ja nicht, künftig sozusagen in unseren Computern dafür sorgen, dass wir solche bösen Sachen wie Kopierschutz nicht mehr machen sollen.
Ja, die Frage ist ja auch erstmal, wir müssen erstmal erklären, wie funktioniert DRM. DRM seht ihr bei den ganzen neuen kommerziellen Musikplattformen, auch iTunes hat das Ganze drin, der radikale Wandel zu früher ist. Früher habt ihr eine CD verkauft, konntet sie auf Ebay stellen, konntet sie weiterverleihen und verschenken, verkaufen und so weiter. Und ihr konntet mit dem physischen Datenträger-CD machen, was ihr wolltet, Zepts kaputt schlagen und so weiter. Und mittlerweile durch DRM erwerbt ihr gar nicht mehr irgendwie einen Tonträger oder eine MP3 oder sonst irgendwie, ihr erwerbt eine Lizenz, eine Nutzungslizenz. Und diese Nutzungslizenz kann euch natürlich auch entzogen werden vom Hersteller. Das bedeutet halt, wenn ihr euch Musik runterladet und dann gibt es irgendein Problem mit eurem Computer aufgrund einen neuen Virus. Und der Computer möchte Apple ansprechen und Apple fragen, ob die MP3s jetzt abgespielt werden dürfen. Und der Apple findet dann bei euch irgendwie einen Virus drauf und sagt dann, nee, ist nichts. Dann habt ihr zwar für die Musik zum Beispiel bezahlt, aber ihr dürft da nichts mitmachen. Oder ihr habt für Musik bezahlt, sei es 1 Euro oder 1, 50 Euro und ihr dürft da nur zweimal Kopien machen. Dann geht die erste Kopie auf euren iPod, die zweite geht auf eure CD. Die CD verschenkt ihr mal an euren besten Freund und dann crash der Computer. Dann ist die Musik gar nicht mehr da, obwohl ihr genauso viel ausgegeben habt wie für eine CD und so weiter. Und da gibt es aber auch unterschiedliche Modelle, also nicht jeder verwendet DHM. Also zum Beispiel Finetunes ist eine ganz coole Plattform von Indylabels für Indie-Hörer hauptsächlich. Und da kann man sich zum Beispiel aussuchen, ob man das Ganze im.oc-Format oder im mp3-Format, also komplett kopierschutzfrei herunterladen kann und dafür halt Geld bezahlt, was dann halt auch teilweise an die Künstler zurückgeht.
Und künftig soll es durch Kopierschutz eben sichergestellt sein, dass die bisherigen Strukturen, man kauft sich sozusagen ein Stück Musik und das ist dann auch wirklich seins. Und es gehört einem und man kann es nicht wirklich kopieren. Kann man zwar heute schon, sozusagen dieses Verkaufsmodell probiert man weiter aufrecht zu erhalten. Nutzt sieht das auch ganz viele Nachteile mit sich. Und zwar, dass DRM erst einmal nicht mit jedem System funktioniert. Gerade freie Betriebssysteme haben oft Probleme, diese ganzen DRM-Funktionen zu unterstützen.
Also ich hab Linux zum Beispiel und Linux ist ein tolles Betriebssystem, aber ich kann mir keine Digital Rights Management-Belieder runterladen. Und damit werde ich halt eigentlich ausgeschlossen. Also ich werde eigentlich eine Illegalität hineingetrieben.
Moment, warum wirst du in die Illegalität getrieben? Also du kannst ja diese Dateien holen und kannst du sie abspielen?
Nein, also du brauchst ja meistens bei diesen kommerziellen DRM-Angeboten nur spezielle Software. Auch Apple funktioniert nur mit iTunes und so weiter. Und für Linux gibt es das meistens nicht. Da habe ich auch Frau Zypries gesagt, unsere Justizministerin, was würde ich denn machen als Linux-Nutzeichen? Möchte da halt unbedingt Musik mehr kaufen. Da meinte sie, ich sollte mir selbst was programmieren. Und da konnte ich auch nur erklären, das geht nicht wegen dem Urheberrecht.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn die Bundesjustizministerin dir das gestattet, also was willst du denn mehr?
Naja, also die ist im Endeffekt nicht die Anwälte. Sie ist nicht der Richter im Endeffekt, der mir dann aufgrund des Gesetzestextes sagt, naja, Pech gehabt.
Naja, und dann gibt es auch das andere Problem, wenn denn, also wir haben ja so eine Musikindustrie-Landschaft so mit fünf großen Firmen oder vier mittlerweile, die kaufen sich ja auch gegenseitig auf. Und wenn wir hauptsächlich Musik von denen beziehen und das auch im Internet tun und irgendwie wollen wir sie ja auch, dann sollen wir sie dann ja auch bezahlen mit diesen 99 Cent pro Stück, dann müssen wir auch irgendwie das Geld denen zukommen lassen. Und dazu wissen sie ja auch automatisch, wer wir sind. Und dann wissen halt wenige Hände von Firmenchefs, wer sich alles, welche Musik genau runterlädt und welche Interessen da hat. Und da müssen wir als pflichtbewusste Datenschützer auch mal ein bisschen warnen und sagen, dass die DM bürgerrechtlich eigentlich total für die Hose ist.
Ja, aber wir leben in einem Land, in dem die Mehrzahl der Menschen sagt, ja ich hab doch nichts zu verbergen. Natürlich möchte ich das nicht, aber die, die alle nichts zu verbergen haben, darum auch nur Postkarten benutzen, weil es ja auch günstiger ist, kriegen wir es in deren Köpfe.
Stell dir mal vor, Italien ist nicht weit weg. Italien, Berlusconi kontrolliert 90% der Medien. Und irgendwelche Berlusconi-Sender speichern mal kurz 10 Jahre lang, was für Musik du hörst. Und dann wissen die Datenbanken im Endeffekt mehr über dich und deine Persönlichkeit, als du wahrscheinlich jemals mit einem Psychiater herausfinden möchtest.
Vermutlich. In den USA sind sie doch schon so weit, dass dieses, was ist es, das TiVo, also dieses, wie nennt man es, dieses Electronic Program Guide System, das die digitalen Videorekorder steuert, tatsächlich aufzeichnet, was du guckst. Und zwar ist das rausgekommen, als die aus Versehen haben gesagt haben, naja, keine Szene ist so oft zurückgespult und nochmal geguckt worden, wie, ich glaube, diese entblößte Brust von Janet Jackson.
Ja, das Ziel des Ganzen ist, dir genau auf deine Person zugeschnittene Werbung in der Werbepause zu präsentieren. Deswegen wird es auch verboten jetzt irgendwie in Amerika über gerichtlichen Weg, dass diese digitalen Videorekorder die Werbung heraus schneiden, automatisch.
Ja, aber das ist ja noch okay. Das kann ich ja noch mit leben, wenn ich handisch vorspulen muss. Mach ich ja jetzt auch. Aber ich möchte bitte nicht, dass das irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, die Firma, von der ich meinen digitalen Videorekorder habe, weiß, welche Szene ich mir wie oft angeguckt habe. Wo kommen wir denn dahin?
Worauf ich auch gerade noch beim Chatchen gewiesen werde, wir haben ja auch ein Chat zu dieser Sendung, irk.freenode.net Channel Chaosradio, dass dieser TCPA-Chip, der sozusagen die Kontrolle über die Musik oder die Kunstwerke, die wir irgendwie konsumieren sollen, wir sind alle Konsumenten oder verbrauchen sollen, dass dieser Chip auch seinen Weg natürlich in den CD-Player finden soll und dass er dann auch CD's nur abrutschtet werden können, wenn der Chip überprüft, ob alles okay ist.
Also euch bringen dann eure 1, 5 TB MP3s nicht mehr, wenn zukünftig die nächste Windows-Generation sagt, naja, also den MP3s vertraue ich jetzt nicht mehr. Ich hab gerade nach Hause telefoniert und zu Hause meinte, naja, die Songs kennen wir nicht, die kommen irgendwie aus illegalen Quellen, also erstmal nix abspielen.
Dann hören wir in Zukunft keine Musik mehr. Weil es so eine Idee ist, offensichtlich nicht so gut angekommen.
Zwei Minuten auf Mitternacht.
Chaosradio 98 ist es, was ihr hört auf Fritz. Vergütung im Netz ist eigentlich unser Thema.
Genau, die letzte Stunde bricht so langsam an und jetzt wollen wir auch endlich mal so einen positiven Blick wagen. Man kann ja auch doch wirklich sinnvoll Vergütung treiben im Netz, denken sich einige Leute. Und dazu werden wir jetzt auch demnächst telefonieren mit Volker Grasseburg, einem Kulturwissenschaftler von der Humboldt-Universität zu Berlin.
Und der wird unter anderem eine Frage beantworten, die die Anne aus Kreuzberg hier an der Fritz-Ortlein 033 171 97 110 stellen will. Anne?
Ja, also meine Frage ist, ja, also wenn sich jetzt eben alle umsonst ihre Musik aus dem Netz runterladen, wie kriegen die Künstler eben ihr Geld? Gibt es da irgendwelche Alternativen, Modelle?
Ja, das ist genau das, was wir glaube ich jetzt in der nächsten Stunde, also in der letzten Stunde unserer Sendung zu beantworten versuchen wollen.
Darauf wollen wir jetzt hinaus. Vielen Dank für die Frage. Muss doch endlich mal gestellt werden.
Eben.
Zum Beispiel solche Sachen denkbar. Was wäre, wenn wir einfach nur so einen Knopf an unseren Filesharing-Versionen hätten, wo man sagt, ey, den Künstler, den ich hier gerade runtergeladen habe, deren Song finde ich cool, gib dir mal einen Euro. Wenn das funktionieren würde und auch auf einer ziemlich minimalen Ebene, wo nicht so viele Leute auf dem Zwischenweg was verlieren würden, denke ich mal, würdest du auf diesen Knopf drücken oder?
Ja, ja. Also ich würde das gerne machen, dass ich eben diese Musikindustrie umgehen könnte, Gamer und so, und den Künstlern das eben direkt zukommen lassen würde. Das finde ich eigentlich, fände ich eine faire Methode.
Zumal man hier nochmal differenzieren möchte, die Musikindustrie und die Gamer sind eigentlich nochmal zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe, weil die Gamer ja eigentlich nur Zusammenschluss der Musiker ist, die ihre Interessen wahrnehmen wollen.
Die Gamer ist ja grundsätzlich nichts Böses.
Ist ja eigentlich was Gutes. Die wurde ja gegründet, weil man halt irgendwie festgestellt hatte, dass jetzt in öffentlichen Einrichtungen irgendwie Musik gespielt wird und die Musiker nicht unbedingt was davon bekommen. Und deswegen gibt es halt diese Pauschalabgaben schon öfters drauf hingewiesen in dieser Sendung, die eben die Gamer einsammelt und an die Musiker ausschüttert, je nachdem wie oft sie gehört werden oder nicht. Und die Gamer ist eigentlich vollkommen selbstorganisiert von den Musikern. Aber wenn da jetzt Musiker sagen, hey, der Laden ist scheiße, gefällt mir nicht, da gehe ich jetzt auch nicht mehr zur Mitgliederversammlung hin, dann ist natürlich auch deren Stimmrecht irgendwie verwirkt.
Achso, der letzte Hort des Sozialismus eigentlich, die Gamer.
Sollte es sein.
Sollte es sein. Anne, wir versuchen deine Frage zu beantworten im Folgenden.
Ja, ich möchte gerne noch einen Lob an Katharina aussprechen, die ganz tolle Musik macht.
Ja, sehr gut Katharina, sag Danke.
Sie hat auch unkündigt, dass sie die Playlist danach später noch ins Netz stellen will.
Das sehen wir dann was im Radio.
chaosradio.ccc.de Wir hören jetzt mal fünf Minuten lang Katharinas Musik und dann versuchen wir Fragen zu antworten. Danke Anne. Die Statistiker unter euch werden jetzt sagen, das waren aber nur viereinhalb Minuten, die wir hinter der Musik von Katharina lauschen durften. Ja, ja, ja, Chaosradio 98 ist es, dass ihr hört und Vergütung im Netz ist unser Thema. Wir haben jetzt den ganzen Abend schon darüber gesprochen, wo ihr Musik herkriegt, wie ihr damit umgeht, was die Industrie vor hat, um euch daran zu hindern, mit Musik zu machen, was ihr mit Musik machen wollt. Und die Frage, die noch gar nicht geklärt ist, die lautet, wie kommt eigentlich der Künstler an sein Geld? Denn der hat auch ein berechtigtes Interesse daran, Geld zu verdienen, um seine Miete zu bezahlen, was zu essen zu bezahlen und vielleicht auch den einen oder anderen Urlaub oder das ein oder andere Automobil, damit er nicht, wie die Leute, die diese Sendung hier machen, Mercedes fahren muss, die fast 20 Jahre alt sind.
Du Armer?
Ich Armer, ja du auch. Du wirst dich noch wundern. Es gibt jemanden, das ist der Volker Grasmuck, den haben wir angerufen, der kennt ein alternatives Finanzierungsmodell.
Kannst du uns bitte erst nochmal kurz quasi zusammenfassen, was denn so die Nachteile von dem Modell sind, was sich die Musikindustrie vorstellt, nämlich per Kopierschutz und weiterhin Songs als, ja oder DRM Restriction Management, Songs einzeln separat im Netz zu verkaufen?
Das Hauptproblem daran ist, dass die, dass es jemand bezahlen muss. DRM ist ja ziemlich teuer, es ist teuer zu entwickeln, es ist teuer auszurollen, es gibt Milliarden von Geräten in den Haushalten, die erst mal mit DRM ausgestattet werden müssen und das muss auch ständig weiterentwickelt werden. Wir haben es mit einem Waffenwettlauf zu tun, weil natürlich die Dinge gehackt werden, dann wieder neu entwickelt werden müssen. Diese neuen Software-Module müssen dann eingespielt werden auf die installierte Software und Hardware. Dann gibt es zentrale Infrastrukturen für die Schlüsselverwaltung beispielsweise, die auch bezahlt werden muss, auch ziemlich kostspielig. Und wer bezahlt das letztendlich? Natürlich die Kunden einerseits und die Urheber andererseits. Denn die Musiker bekommen heute in ihren Verträgen bereits auferlegt eine neue Formatklausel. Das heißt, die Rechteinhaber, die Verwerter sagen, wir müssen all das bezahlen und ihr müsst euren Teil dazu beitragen. Also kriegt ihr weniger Geld von uns.
Also wäre das mit anderen Worten für kleinere Musiker insbesondere nicht wirklich rentabel?
Für kleinere Musiker, die bei kleinen Labels unter Vertrag sind, wird das mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht bezahlbar sein. Letztendlich kann sich ein einzelner Musiker oder eine einzelne Band eine solche Infrastruktur sowieso nicht leisten. Und inwieweit sich die Indylabels zusammen tun können, um solche Infrastrukturen zu errichten oder sich irgendwo einkaufen können, das ist sehr die Frage. Vor allen Dingen aber zeichnet sich bereits ab, dass die das nicht wollen. Das wollen übrigens auch durchaus große Plattenfirmen wie Universal nicht, die mit DRM, mit Kopierschutzmaßnahmen auf ihren Musik-CDs experimentiert haben und das wieder eingestellt haben. Also hier gibt es auch ein Element von Kundenbindung. Man hat also erkannt, dass man mit solchen technischen Verhinderungsmaßnahmen Leute abschreckt und tatsächlich noch dazu beiträgt, dass sie eben keine CDs mehr kaufen, sondern sich die Musik zum Beispiel aus Peer-to-Peer-Filesharing-Systemen holen.
Und was glaubst du, welche Chancen kann sich die Musikindustrie verstielen, wenn sie eben auf sowas wie DRM setzen würden?
Naja, in allererster Linie wird sie erst mal ihre Kunden verprägen. Und wie nachhaltig eine solche Infrastruktur aufrecht zu erhalten ist, das ist noch sehr die Frage. Das einzige System, das für Musikverkauf im Netz abgefeiert wird von allen Seiten, von der Industrie, aber auch durchaus von Politikern, ist sehr wahrscheinlich heute Abend schon zur Sprache gekommen, also Apples iTunes. Und da ist ja durchaus sehr fraglich, ob die Querfinanzierung durch die Abspielgeräte, denn Apple verdient ja nichts an diesem Musiksystem, dazu führt, dass dieses Computerunternehmen sich das lange wird leisten kann. Vor allen Dingen aber ist es erstaunlich, dass dieses extrem leaky DRM-System, das Apple hier einsetzt, also sozusagen ein Scheunentor für die Durchlässigkeit von vermeintlich geschützten Musikstücken bietet, dass die Musikindustrie da lange mitspielen wird, weil die natürlich auch sehen, dass Stücke, die in iTunes neu eingestellt werden, innerhalb kürzester Zeit dann in P2P-Netzen auftauchen.
Volker, du hast dich damit ausgiebig beschäftigt und dir auch überlegt, wie man es besser machen kann. Was ist denn da dein Konzept?
Ja, nochmal die Problembeschreibung vielleicht, um damit zu beginnen. Tauschbörsen wachsen weiter. Die Behauptung der Musikindustrie, dass die Aufklärung, vor allen Dingen aber die Kampagnen zur strafrechtlichen und zivilrechtlichen Verfolgung von Filesharern, Früchte tragen, dass also die Nutzung zurückgeht, sind eindeutig falsch. Die Zahlen, die von solchen Unternehmen wie Big Champagne, dem wichtigsten Peer-to-Peer-Marktforschungsunternehmen in den USA, oder auch Cashlogic, ein britisches Unternehmen vorgelegt werden, zeigen, dass das Filesharing weiter wächst und zwar sowohl nach Nutzerzahlen, wie nach Transaktionszahlen, wie nach Zahl der Werke, die in diesem System verfügbar sind. Es ist also damit zu rechnen, dass auch in Deutschland die weitere Strategie, Filesharer zu verklagen, nicht den erwünschten Erfolg haben wird, was bietet das Urheberrecht an Mitteln für Filesharing? Das ist zunächst mal der Umgehungsschutz für DRM. Und wir hatten ja bereits gesagt, dass DRM nicht ernsthaft dazu beiträgt, dass mit DRM geschützte Werke nicht in Peer-to-Peer-Netzen auftauchen. Und es ist eben die Klagemöglichkeit. Im jetzt aktuellen zweiten Korb soll eine Grauzone geschwärzt werden. Seit Ende vergangenen Jahres ist sehr deutlich verboten, Dinge in Peer-to-Peer-Netzen anzubieten. Aber nach der Begründung des Bundesjustizministeriums ist es im Augenblick noch möglich, sich damit herauszureden, dass man sagt, man sei davon ausgegangen, dass das Musikstück, das man heruntergeladen hat, eine rechtmäßig hergestellte Privatkopie sei und sich damit erfolgreich verteidigen kann. Diese Möglichkeit soll mit dem zweiten Korb geschlossen werden und damit ist das Instrumentarium verfügbar, um weiter zu klagen. Aber wie ich eben schon ausgeführt habe, führt auch das nicht dazu, dass Filesharing Nutzung abnimmt. Und das heißt, es werden dort weiter Werke zirkulieren, ohne dass die Urheber vergütet werden. Und das ist natürlich ein Problem. Ich denke, dass das völlig berechtigt ist, auf ein System hinzuarbeiten, das es Urhebern ermöglicht, in Urlaub zu fahren und die Brötchen zu verdienen und sich auch ein Auto zu kaufen.
Und wie kann dieses System aussehen?
Dafür gibt es ein bewährtes Verfahren, die Privatkopie-Schranke erlaubt ist, privat zu kopieren und verpflichtet diejenigen, die davon Gebrauch machen können, eine Vergütung dafür zu bezahlen. Das tun wir alle, wenn wir Aufnahmegeräte kaufen und Lehrmedien. Das geht dann an die Verwertungsgesellschaften und die schütten diese Beträge an die Urheber aus. Das ist vom Gesetzgeber schon in den 60er Jahren eingeführt worden mit der Begründung, dass eine Kontrolle des privaten Kopierens nicht möglich wäre und alles, was denen damals eingefallen ist, hätte außerdem zu einer Verletzung der Privatsphäre geführt und das ist ja schließlich auch ein Rechtsgut, was geschützt ist. Und insofern ist diese Konstruktion einerseits lässt man etwas zu, was man ohnehin nicht verhindern kann, andererseits macht man es vergütungspflichtig eingeführt worden und das ist auch das Modell für peer-to-peer Filesharing, was wir heute vorschlagen.
Also eine Lehrmedienabgabe auf das Internet?
In einer gewissen Weise, genau. Auch hier wird man eine Stelle suchen, an der ohnehin schon Zahlungen erfolgen. Jeder, der im Internet ist, bezahlt seinem ISP, seinem Internetzugangsprovider eine monatliche Gebühr. Das wäre eine Stelle, auf der man einen Betrag von zum Beispiel 5 Euro für einen Breitbandzugang aufschlagen könnte. Es ist natürlich auch vorstellbar zu sagen, dass die Anbieter von peer-to-peer Filesharing-Software hier in die Pflicht genommen werden. Das Problem ist nur, dass die bislang noch keinen Zahlkanal haben zu ihren Nutzern, weil diese Software eben kostenlos angeboten wird. Das müsste also praktisch neu etabliert werden. Die ISPs haben diesen Zahlkanal bereits, genauso wie der Handel für Rekorde und Lehrmedien diesen Zahlkanal hat. Aus praktischen Gründen wäre das also naheliegend.
Und wie kommt das Geld bei den Künstländern an? Also jeder bezahlt, sagen wir mal, für sein DSL jetzt 5 Euro im Monat. Da kommt ja schon eine ganze Menge zusammen. Wie wird das ausgeschüttet? Welche Vorteile hat dieses Modell für Künstler? Also abgesehen davon, dass überhaupt ein bisschen Geld reinkommt?
Die ISPs würden diese Beträge abführen an eine Verwertungsgesellschaft. Und diese Verwertungsgesellschaft würde die Beträge an ihre Mitglieder, nämlich die Urheber, ausschütten. Das ist eigentlich ganz genau so, wie das heute auch schon bei den bestehenden Verwertungsgesellschaften funktioniert. Nur, dass es heute bei den werkunspezifischen Beträgen, also bei Beträgen für Rekorder und Lehrmedien, wo man ja nicht weiß, wessen Werke jetzt darauf genutzt worden sind, pauschal auch ausgeschüttet wird, gemäß der Zahlen, die man hat aus dem Airplay, also der Radionutzung und aus den Verkaufszahlen von CDs. Das heißt, wer viel im Radio gespielt wird, bekommt auch den Löwenanteil aus diesen unspezifischen Beträgen. Das können wir im Internet sehr viel genauer machen, weil hier die Downloads relativ trivial festzustellen, zu messen und zusammen zu zählen sind, sodass man am Ende eines Abrechnungszeitraums genau sagen kann, das Werk des Künstlers X ist in diesem Zeitraum so oft heruntergeladen worden und daraus ergibt sich ein prozentualer Anteil aus der Vergütungssumme von Y.
Also ich fasse nochmal zusammen, Kulturflatrate nennt sich diese Idee und ich zahle praktisch eine Lehrmedienabgabe aus dem Internet. Also mit meinem Breitband, mit meinem DSL Zugang zahle ich eine bestimmte Summe monatlich dazu, die dann benutzt wird, um die Künstler im Einzelnen zu vergüten. Sind die fünf Euro, die du eben genannt hast, eine realistische Größe oder ist es jetzt einfach nur eine Diskussionsgrundlage erstmal?
Diese Zahl stammt von einem Professor der Harvard Rechtsuniversität, William Fischer, der sich die Zahlen der Musikindustrie und der Filmindustrie vorgenommen hat, also die Beträge, von denen sie behaupten, dass sie ihnen durch Filesharing entgehen. Hat das zusammengezählt, hat die Zahl der Breitbandnutzer in den USA zusammengezählt und ist auf diesen Betrag von 5 Dollar pro Monat gekommen. Je nach Wechselkurs wäre das also noch ein bisschen weniger, aber die Zahl ist schon als Pi mal Daumenzahl zu sehen. Dafür wird jetzt aber gerade das bestehende Verfahren geändert, angepasst. Die Vergütungsbeträge sind in Deutschland bislang vom Gesetzgeber festgelegt worden. Man kann sich vorstellen, wenn da immer erst das Parlament zusammenkommen muss und über Eurobeträge verhandeln muss, dauert das ziemlich lange. Insofern ist in der aktuellen Novellierung des Urheberrechts vorgesehen, dass hier ein Aushandlungsverfahren der betroffenen Parteien, also einerseits der Verwertungsgesellschaft, andererseits der Zahlungsverpflichteten, in diesem Fall also der ISPs, stattfindet. Und wenn die nicht in einem bestimmten Zeitraum zu einer Einigung kommen, gibt es ein Schiedsverfahren. Und wenn auch das von den Parteien nicht anerkannt wird, gibt es noch eine gerichtliche Instanz darüber. Das soll gewährleisten, dass innerhalb absehbarer Zeit solche Vergütungsbeträge zusammenkommen. Und in die Verhandlungen gehen dann natürlich empirische Informationen ein. Da würde dann gesagt, bestimmte Geräte werden in dem Umfang tatsächlich für die Anfertigung von Kopien genutzt. Und auf diese Weise würde auf empirischer Grundlage festgestellt, wie hoch die Vergütung sein muss.
Volker Grasburg ist Sozialwissenschaftler und Medienforscher und hat nicht nur zur Kulturflatrate geforscht, über die wir uns gerade mit ihm unterhalten haben, sondern zu vielen anderen Themen auch. Und wenn ihr euch informieren wollt, wer Volker Grasburg ist und wozu er geforscht hat, dann könnt ihr das selbstverständlich tun und zwar in der Wikipedia. Chaosradio 98, hört ihr auf Fritz und Vergütung im Netz ist unser Thema heute Abend. Wir haben eben von Volker Grasmuk gehört, es gibt die Idee einer Kultur-Flatrate, ein moment-eigentlich-Konkurrenz-loses Prinzip über Peer-to-Peer-Filesharing oder dafür zu sorgen, dass Künstler, deren Dateien in Peer-to-Peer-Filesharing getauscht werden, auch zu ihrem Geld kommen, denn von irgendwas müssen die ja auch leben. Die Idee ist, 5 Euro im Monat für einen Breitbandanschluss zu zahlen, also jeder, der ein DSL zu Hause hat, zahlt ein Fünfer extra und darf dafür tauschen, so viel und so lange er will. Mal gucken, wie der Christian aus dem Prenzlauer Berg das findet. Christian, ist das eine gute Idee?
Na ja, an sich die Peer-to-Peer-Filesharing-Reworfen dafür zu verwenden, also die Netzwerke zu halten, weil eine bessere Möglichkeit an Informationen und so weiter und an die Daten zu kommen, gibt es einfach mal nicht. Es ist allerdings eine Zumutung jedem DSL-User einfach mal zu sagen, hey, du nutzt das, du machst das, also zahl 5 Euro. Das ist für mich eine Frechheit.
Das ist ähnlich wie Rundfunkgebühren für Leute, die keinen Fernseher haben, meinst du?
Na okay, das kann man ja an dem Augenblick noch abbestellen. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie ist die Lösungsidee von dem Herrn Volker, wenn ich den Namen noch richtig is?
Volker Grasmuck.
Genau, Volker Grasmuck.
Na ja, aber vielleicht, wie wär's mit einer Drossel? Dass du sagst, der 5er Aufpreis ist dafür, dass du wirklich... Das ist eine Voraussetzung.
Obwohl du es gar nicht tust, wenn das dann z.B. so gelöst werden würde.
Also ich wäre mehr so eine Art...
ein bisschen Werbung für die Firma Steam. Hier Half Life 2 ist ein Begriff. Die haben das ja gelöst mit einem Lizenzcode. Man kauft sich halt das Produkt, ob nun im Geschäft mit einer CD oder sonst wie, oder einfach nur online, registriert sich dafür. Und man hat quasi einen Account dort, wo die entsprechenden Daten hinterlegt sind für die Spiele, die man lizenziert hat. Kann sich die dann, egal von wo, aus dem Web laden, kann sich die kaufen oder sich halt irgendwo an einen Terminal brennen lassen, weil man halt die Lizenz dazu erworben hat. Und das ist eine Kontrolle, wie allgemein im öffentlichen Straßenverkehr stattfinden kann. Da machen sie ja auch strichbogenartig Kontrollen, ob du unter Drohung fährst, ob das Auto in Ordnung ist oder legale Waren transportierst oder sonst was. So wäre es dann auch möglich, zum Beispiel den Datenbestand, den eine Person auf der Festplatte oder so gespeichert hat, zu kontrollieren, ob die jeweiligen Lizenzen dafür da sind, dass er berechtigt ist, diese Daten in dieser Form zu speichern. Und die Kontrollen sind eh da.
Wer soll das bitte kontrollieren?
Ja, die Polizei zum Beispiel.
Die Polizei soll auf dein Computer gucken, ob du alle Lizenzen zu der Post mehr hast?
Da machst du aber dein...
Also dann lieber 5 Euro im Monat, oder?
Muss ja nicht unbedingt sein, dass sie einem direkt auf die Festplatte schielen. Wenn sie einem an der Grenze kontrollieren und gucken, ob das Handy klaut ist oder nicht, dann ist es im Prinzip dasselbe. Es ist einfach nur in einer anderen Formel, in einem anderen Umfang.
Naja, aber es ist ziemlich schwer auf der Festplatte zu differenzieren, wo sie hingucken dürfen und wo nicht.
Ja, da gibt es ja nur Möglichkeiten, explizit nach diesen Files zu suchen.
Wer kontrolliert den, der dich kontrolliert? Da bist du dann ganz schnell da, dass du irgendwie immer sagst, ja Moment mal, wenn der diesen Ordner nicht freigegeben hat, dann wird in diesem Ordner bestimmt was drin sein. Und damit machst du dich dann ja schon wieder verdächtig.
Außerdem löst ein Lizenzmodell auch nicht wirklich, denke ich, das Problem davon, dass Filesharing trotzdem funktioniert. Ich meine, dann lädst du dir das einmal mit deiner Lizenz runter und wenn du halt irgendwie eher ein Mensch bist, der das dann auch anderen zur Verfügung stellen willst, scherzt du halt in einer Filesharing-Börse.
Ja, natürlich. Jeder hat im Prinzip die Möglichkeit, ein File, egal ob du es bezahlt hast, vorerst oder nicht, sich runterzuladen. Er kann sich das anhören, zeitlich limitiert. Und entweder ist er dann bereit, dieser Track gefällt mir, ja, ich möchte die Lizenz für den erwerben, kaufe den quasi, kaufe die Lizenz, diesen Track zu nutzen und zu hören. Und in dem Augenblick ist er halt für diesen Track lizenziert. Er kann ihn sich jetzt besorgen, anhören, sonst was machen, wie er möchte. Auf welchem Weg auch immer. Und das halt legal.
Und du meinst darauf lassen sich die Leute ein, wenn sie daneben eine Filesharing-Base laufen lassen können?
Ja, in dem Augenblick tritt der Gesetzgeber in die Kraft, um zu kontrollieren, dass die Gesetze eingehalten werden. Und wie gesagt, es ist doch im Prinzip dasselbe.
Kannst du Menschen, die kiffen? Zum Thema Gesetzgeber und so weiter. Wir haben seit Jahrzehnten ein Cannabisverbot und es gibt ca. 4 Millionen Cannabiskonsumenten in Deutschland. Da kann der Gesetzgeber auch nicht so durchgreifen, wie das so bestimmte Leute und Hardliner und so weiter wünschen.
Ja, jetzt ist die Frage, ob er kann oder ob er einfach nicht will, weil sich das vielleicht zu großen Unmut anziehen würde.
Also du hättest dann eben wirklich einen Polizeistaat. Also das ist eben das Problem. Du hättest hinter jedem Bürger einen Polizisten stehen, der darauf aufpasst, dass dieser Bürger sich auch garantiert gesetzeskonform verhält.
Das Problem ist ja... Genau das Gleiche machen sie doch im Straßenverkehr auch. Doch, tun sie.
Na ja, der Straßenverkehr... Sie tun es, aber das ist ja nun wirklich eine Alibi-Variante, weil der Straßenverkehr ja auch ausschließlich deshalb funktioniert, weil permanent Regeln gegen Regeln verstoßen wird. Wenn jeder im Straßenverkehr sich an die Regeln halten würde, würde das nicht funktionieren.
Ja, natürlich, dann bräuchten wir, wenn sich jeder an die Regeln halten würde, was das Lizenzrecht angeht, dann würde das doch auch ohne Kontrolle nicht funktionieren. Aber es funktioniert nun mal nicht, genauso wie im Straßenverkehr. Das ist das Problem.
Ja, aber du kannst es doch überhaupt nicht überwachen.
Ja, kannst du den Straßenverkehr überwachen? Weißt du, wie viele nachts breit über die Straßen fahren?
Ich weiß das. Ich fahre morgens um 4 zur Arbeit.
Ach du bist das. Dann verstehst du das. Und in dem Augenblick haben wir ein paar Glück gehabt, dass wir irgendwann mal durch eine Strichprobe erwischt werden.
Wie Sportfahren.
Ja, aber das ist der Zustand, den wir im Moment schon haben. Filesharing gibt es, das wird es immer geben. Das werden sie nicht verhindern können. Und ab und zu mal picken sie sich jemanden raus und der wird dann verknackt.
Ja, aber in dem Augenblick, wo man das auf solch breiter Basis anbieten kann, mit einfachen preiswerten Lizenzen in Massen, wirklich in Massen, wenn viel mehr Leute kaufen würden, dann würde der Produktions- und der Verkaufspreis nicht bei 1, 50 Euro liegen, den er von ihr nannt hat.
Das war, die ZD-Preise sind ja auch nicht gesunken, so, auch nicht so hochzeitende der 90er.
Es ist einfach zu teuer gewesen, die Masse konnte sich oder wollte sich das für die gebotene Leistung einfach nicht leisten. Und hat gesagt, wir besorgen uns das halt auf anderem Wege. Hätten sie die Preise akzeptabel gehalten, dann würden viel mehr Leute auch den Service von der ZD nutzen wollen und sich die Daten halt wirklich legal besorgen, als wenn sie eben anfangen. Naja, es lohnt sich halt. Es ist doch eine horrende Summe, die zusammenkommt, wenn ich jetzt meine Musik, die ich hier höre, z.B. bezahlen müsste.
Sag uns lieber nicht, wie viel das ist. Wir machen Nachrichten. Danke, Christian. Tschüss und gute Nacht.
Wenn Fritz in Rathenow, dann 100 2, 6.
3, 5 1.
Heute Nacht meist stark bewirrt und regnerisch. Die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen plus 3 und null Grad. Also Kratzen, Frost usw. Am Tag erwarten uns viele Wolken. Es kann ab und zu leicht regnen. Morgen und die Temperaturen steigen auf 4 bis 6 Grad. Jetzt gibt es Meldungen mit Gerald Götterheinrich.
Wo ist denn das Mikrofon plötzlich hin? Im Machtkampf in der Ukraine gibt es einen ersten Kompromiss. Regierung und Opposition wollen erst einmal eine Entscheidung des obersten Gerichts abwarten. Außerdem will die Opposition die Regierungsgebäude vorerst nicht mehr blockieren. Im Folterskandal bei der Bundeswehr wird derzeit in 12 Verdachtsfällen ermittelt. Verteidigungsminister Strupp warnte aber vor einem Generalverdacht gegen die Bundeswehr. Es gäbe rund 12.000 Ausbilder, bis zu 40 von ihnen würden jetzt überprüft. Die Regierungskoalition in Israel ist auseinandergebrochen. Anlass war der Streit um den Staatshaushalt für das kommende Jahr. Die Shinui-Partei hatte Regierungschef Sharon im Parlament die Gefolgschaft verweigert und gegen den Etat gestimmt. Prinz Bernhard der Niederlande ist tot. Der Vater von Königin Beatrix stirbt nach schwerer Krankheit im Alter von 93 Jahren in einem Krankenhaus in Utrecht. Bei einem Wechsel des Mobilfunknetzbetreibers darf die Mitnahme der Handynummer nicht mehr als 29, 95 Euro kosten. Diese Obergrenze hat jetzt die Regulierungsbehörde für Post- und Telekommunikation festgelegt. Und Sport im UEFA-Pokal hat Schalke 04 mit einer Niederlage den Gruppensieg in der Zwischenrunde verspielt. Der bereits für die nächste Runde qualifizierte Fußball-Bundesligist verlor beim niederländischen Meister Feyenoord Rotterdam mit 1 zu 2. Der Verkehr fritzt keine aktuellen Meldungen mehr. Im Moment gute Fahrt für euch.
Vielen Dank, Gerald. Gott sei Dank. Fünf nach halb eins.
Ein Event. Ein Event, das umgangssprachlich für kulturelles Ereignis.
Und Fritz hat davon gleich einen ganzen Kalender.
Der Fritz-Eventskalender gewinnt im Advent jeden Tag Tickets für ein Event. Konzerte von den Toten Hosen, Rammstein, Nia, Green Day, The Roots, Gala, Silbermond und den Beastie Boys. Der Fritz-Eventskalender, noch bis zum 24.
Dezember und im Radio.
Dreiste Musik, Fritz.
In den letzten Zügen liegt Chaosradio 98, Vergütung im Netz unser Thema und die konkreteste Idee, die es da derzeit gibt, ist die Kulturflatrate. Also praktisch eine Pauschalabgabe auf einen Breitbandanschluss und zwar auf einen jeden Breitbandanschluss. Das heißt DSL plus fünf Euro, dafür so viel runterladen wie ihr wollt. Eli aus Karlsbad.
Ich halte das für ja eigentlich eine gute Theorie, aber ich sag mal, man kann nicht allen Internet-Nutzern, die irgendwie einen Breitbandanschluss haben, fünf Euro abknöpfen. Ich halte das für ein bisschen unfair. Das ist so, als ob ich irgendwie...
Na komm, aber wozu brauchst du wirklich einen Breitbandanschluss?
Nicht unbedingt. Also ich sag mal, ich bin Linux-Nutzer und ich weiß, dass meine Hauptlast eigentlich daraus besteht, dass ich mir irgendwelche Isos neu saug oder beziehungsweise mein System aktuell halt. Also es sind teilweise schon extreme Datenmengen wasserfließend. Also es muss nicht unbedingt sein, dass es illegaler Content ist.
Es wäre dann ja kein illegaler Content mehr, den du da verschieben würdest. Also andersherum gefragt, warum lädst du dir keine Musik runter?
Ich lad mir hin und wieder schon Musik runter. Also? Ja, aber ich sag mal so, wenn mir wirklich ein Album gefällt, dann geh ich in den Laden und kauf mir das. Also wenn mir wirklich ein ganzes Album gefällt und ich mir nicht nur einzelne Lieder hör, dann sag ich, ich will dem Künstler auch irgendwas zurückgeben und dann kauf ich mir das Album. Oder wenn es zum Beispiel die Chance gäbe, dass jeder Künstler auf seiner Homepage irgendwas über Paypal hat, wenn er sich das versagt, dieses Donationprogramm sozusagen, dann würde ich da wahrscheinlich auch was über den Weg geben. Aber so pauschal, jedem was abzupacken, das wäre wie, als ob man, ich weiß nicht, als ob man irgendjemanden eine Strafgebühr für irgendwie Falschparken gibt, einfach jedem Autofahrer, obwohl man überhaupt nicht weiß, ob er Falschparkt.
Schönes Beispiel, was genau dasselbe ist, Eigenheimzulage. Ich zahle dafür, dass andere Leute sich ein Haus bauen können. Das Problem ist, wir haben solche Sachen. Geht weiter Pendlerpauschale. Andere, die überhaupt kein Auto haben, aber Steuern zahlen dafür, dass ich Geld dafür kriege, dass ich zur Arbeit und zurück fahre. Das ist völlig absurd. Ich meine, da kann ich doch so was noch oben draufsetzen.
Ja, es ist absurd, finde ich.
Also gerade als Linux-Nutzer bist du ja auch sehr durch DRM gefährdet und TCPA und so weiter. Und so eine Kulturflatrate wäre halt die Alternative dazu.
Ich sag mal so, durch DRM habe ich gemerkt, dass Randgruppen wohl keine Menschen sein können. Weil, ich weiß, ja, das war jetzt eher als Scherz gedacht. Also ich sag mal so, wenn wirklich DRM durchkommt, dann sind erstmal die Linux-Nutzer ausgeschlossen. Auch wenn Linux gemeint hat, dass er dafür wäre, dass DRM in Kernel kommt. Aber es ist bezweifelig, dass die das zulassen. Ja, eben. Also ich bezweifle, dass Microsoft es wirklich zulässt, dass Linux auch DRM in Kernel kriegt. Ich denke, die haben genug Macht, um das irgendwie zu verhindern. Zumindest in ihrer, ich sag mal, TCMPA-Group.
Ja, und ist dir dann nicht irgendwie die Weiterbenutzung von Linux 5 Euro im Monat wert? Und dazu noch irgendwie so viel Musik und Filme runterladen, wie du möchtest? Und das ohne schlechtes Gewissen? Und die Künstler bekommen auch was da noch?
Ich find das mal so geil.
Also das ist jetzt, ich sag mal, sehr utopisch. Also ich bezweifle, dass es so, so was, also das ist solche Alternativen.
Es funktioniert seit 40 Jahren so, ne?
Nur halt nicht im Internet, sondern eben auf Leer-CDs und Leerkassetten. Und da ist natürlich auch eine gewisse Ungerechtigkeit gegeben. Klar, weil es eben pauschal sein muss, um diesen Kontrollmoment zu verhindern.
Es gibt Leute, die zum Beispiel einen Videorecorder nur nutzen, um ihre eigenen Sachen irgendwie zu schneiden oder aufzunehmen. Und andere Leute nutzen Videorecorder, um wiederum Filme aus dem Fernsehen aufzunehmen. Das wär ja eigentlich auch per se ungerecht so.
Gut, Kittes, wir sind nicht hier um Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten. Eli, was für alternative Ideen hättest du denn, wie man die Künstler zu Geld kommen lässt?
Ähm, ich sag mal irgendwie an das Gedächtnis an das Hirn des Menschen zu appellieren. Weil ich mein, dass man einfach den Leuten ne Chance gibt, dass sie für die Künstler selber was spenden können, zum Beispiel über Paypal oder über was auch immer. Und dass es dann ihre freie Entscheidung ist, dass man Geld gibt. Zudem hab ich mal irgendwo glaub ich ne Statistik gelesen. Ich weiß nicht, ob die seriös waren. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob da überhaupt was dran ist. Auf jeden Fall wurde da zumindest behauptet, dass die Musikindustrie durch diese ganze, ich sag mal, Runterlad-Boom, der zurzeit ja herrscht immer noch, mehr profitiert, als irgendwie Geld abgeben muss. Weil die Leute einfach die Chance haben, sich bevor sie eine CD kaufen, das Zeug anzuhören und dann wahrscheinlich, oder zumindest nach der Statistik zufolge, öfters eine CD kaufen, als sie ohne Reinhörn kaufen würden.
Und du hättest das gerne lieber auf freiwilliger Basis, als dass man so einen Spendenknopf hat. Glaubst du, das würde funktionieren im Land der Schmarotzer? Wie wir das ja immer wieder zu sagen bekommen von unserer Ödigkeit.
Und Pisa und so weiter.
Ich glaub schon, ja. Also ich kenne sehr viele, die zwar auch runterladen, aber so wie ich machen, wenn ihnen wirklich was gefällt, dass sie es dann auch kaufen. Und ich denke, es ist einfach eine bessere Lösung, weil man kann es nicht umgehen. Ich meine, sobald ein neuer Kopierschutz da ist, ist innerhalb von nächsten, also einen Tag bis einer Woche, spätestens irgendwie ein passender Crack dafür da. Man kann es nicht verhindern, man kann nur an das Hirn und an das Verständnis von Leuten appellieren.
Also da sind wir uns ja einig, dass wir solche Kopierschutzsysteme auch gar nicht mehr brauchen. Also wie Musikindustrie das haben möchte.
Ja, die stecken eigentlich viel zu viel Geld da rein. Die könnten die CDs billiger machen, deutlich billiger, anstatt da rein zu investieren. Und dadurch würden sich auch vielleicht mehr Leute CDs kaufen.
Interessanterweise hat der Kollege Paul von Dück gerade angerufen. Draußen bei Gary an der Hotline. Und fragt nochmal, für alle, kann ich das auch nochmal erklären, die es nicht mitbekommen haben, Kulturflatrate war ja eben unser Thema. Also eine quasi Lehrmedienabgabe auf das Internet. Also jeder, der einen Breitbandanschluss hat, zahlt beispielsweise 5 Euro. Und das Geld wird hergenommen, um an die Künstler ausgezahlt zu werden, die dann runtergeladen werden. Und Paul fragt, nach welchem Schlüssel soll denn mit den Künstlern abgerechnet werden? Also wie viel kriegen die kreativeren bzw. weniger kreativen Leute?
Das wird ja genau irgendwie nach Konsum ermittelt. Also nicht irgendwie, was läuft im Radio, sondern irgendwie, wie viele Lieder von Paul von Dyck bandern tatsächlich herum und werden auch deswegen gehört. Also wie viele Fans gibt es da draußen? Das kann man ja mit Radio und Fernsehen im Moment nicht ermitteln, aber durch das Internet wird das möglich.
Das ist relativ simpel.
Das ist ja die älteste Frage, seitdem man diese Pauschalabgabe hat, seit den 60ern. Und da gab es ja, wie Volker auch schon meinte, Schlüssel, die sich aus den Verkaufszahlen generieren, aus dem, was im Radio gespielt wird. Und es spricht ja auch nichts dagegen, dass diese Werte mit als Faktor in diesen Schlüssel mit reinfließen, über die sich ja die GEMA schon lange Zeit Gedanken gemacht hat. Und das auch ziemlich gut und einen ziemlich umfangreichen Schlüssel eigentlich gefunden hat. Ob das jetzt politisch so korrekt ist, kleinere Musiker ist immer die Frage, aber das ist auch eine Sache, die haben dann die Künstler in ihrer Verwertungsgesellschaft, die zu gewinnen ist, zu entscheiden. Und es ist eben ein großer Vorteil, dass man im Internet auch stichprobenartig eben Tauschbörsen sozusagen analysieren kann und gucken kann, was ist gerade der Trend, der wird mehr oder weniger getauscht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es ist doch sogar zu 100% erstildbar. Es ist technisch sehr simpel, nachzuvollziehen, wer wie oft runtergeladen wurde und der kriegt dann eben das meiste Geld, der am häufigsten runtergeladen wurde. Ich hoffe, Pauls Frage ist damit beantwortet. Wir haben noch einen Anrufer an, Herr Fritzotlein. 0331 77 97 110 Und das ist der Steve nochmal aus Hellersdorf. Steve. Hallo. Dauergast.
Ja, irgendwie schon, ja.
Hau rein.
Ja, also ich wollte eigentlich bloß nochmal was dazu sagen, und zwar Vergütung der Musiker. Ich bin ja selber Musiker. Und habe schon einige Erfahrungen mit der GEMA und der GVL gemacht. Und muss eigentlich sagen, dass ich mehr an die GEMA und GVL bezahle, als ich eigentlich von denen zurückgekomme.
Okay, erklär mal das System.
Na, das System ist eigentlich so, also ich bin bei einem Indylabel mit meiner Band. Und wir bezahlen an das Label ein gewisses Grundkapital, wovon die dann sozusagen die CDs produzieren. Die sponsern auch noch ein bisschen was bei. Das Ganze geht dann in den Vertrieb, dann geht das Ganze zum Presswerk und so weiter und so fort. Vom Presswerk aus geht dann auch ein bisschen was an die GEMA und an die GVL. Und wir kriegen dann letztendlich irgendwie ein paar Fannyke zurück.
Nun ist das ja zum einen die GEMA, wie du meinst. Unsere Vorstellung ist eher, dass man eine neue Verwertungsgesellschaft schafft, die das reguliert. Und wenn man heute viel an die GEMA zahlt, heißt das ja nicht, dass man das nicht auch besser machen kann. Und zum anderen ist ja die GEMA demokratisch bestimmt durch ihre Mitglieder. Und die können halt auch von ihrer Mitgliederversammlung entscheiden, was und wie hoch die Kosten für die einzelnen Mitglieder sind. Und dadurch, dass viele Musiker auf den ersten Blick meinen, die GEMA ist eigentlich so ein Doverhaufen, dann freut man sich auch gar nicht so richtig damit an und verlieren auch sozusagen neben ihrem Einfluss eine Einflussmöglichkeit als Mitglied, die sich in diesem Zusammenschluss der Musiker anschließen können, nicht wirklich wahr.
Ja, das Problem ist aber einfach bloß, wenn man sozusagen CDs in einem Pressehalt machen lassen will, dass man einfach bloß GEMA schon ein Mitglied sein muss und einfach mal auch schon gewisse Gebühren abzahlen muss, bevor man überhaupt irgendeinen gepresteten Wert in der Hand halten muss.
Also euer Hauptproblem ist, ihr werdet nicht im Radio gespielt. Das ist der Hauptnachteil nach dem wertzeitigen System.
Aber das muss ja bei so einem neuen Modell gar nicht genau so laufen. Das ist, wie soll ich sagen, zur Gestaltung vorgegeben. Und man kann ja auch sozusagen ein Gesetz verabschieden, das gar keine Mitgliedsbeiträge oder Aufnahmebeiträge geben muss, sondern dass man nur davon als Musiker profitieren kann, was ja auch der eigentliche Gedanke und Sinn dieser Verwertungsgesellschaft ist.
Gut, dann müsste man das Ganze aber gemeinnützig oder vielleicht ehrenamtlich aufzählen.
Das werden wir dann sehen. Volker ist sehr zuversichtlich, was das ganze Ding angeht. Er sagt, es ist im Grunde konkurrenzlos und darum ist die Chance sehr groß, dass es eingeführt wird, weil getauscht werden wird auf jeden Fall immer weiter.
Dann nehmen wir doch einfach einen Vorstand mit rein.
Genau, ist auch ein sehr unzweifelhafter Mensch.
Oder Beirat.
Oder Beirat. Steve, danke für deinen Anruf.
Bitte.
Gute Nacht, tschüss. Hier, hör mal, Jungs, ich hab ne Kurzmitteilung gekriegt von einer Nummer, die mein Telefon mal wieder nicht identifizieren kann, oder was ich im Wesentlichen auf einen Backe in der Sockwärtsrunde...
Du hast dein Telefon hier im Studio.
Ihr könnt noch ankündigen, dass der Fahrplan 1.0 morgen online geht. Versteht ihr irgendjemand, was damit gemein sein könnte?
Könnte der Fahrplan sein für so ne Zugveranstaltung? Nein, für den Chaos Communication Congress des Chaos Computer Clubs zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr.
Aber warum denn Fahrplan?
Der Fahrplan ist sozusagen der Plan, wann die ganzen Veranstaltungen ablaufen.
Verstehe, und wer hat mir diese Nachricht geschrieben?
Höchstwahrscheinlich der Tim Pritloff.
Das geht mir so auf die Ketten, dass mein Telefon sich manchmal einfach weigert zu identifizieren.
Und ab morgen wissen wir dann alle, was wir ausführen.
Wie ausgeschaltet, seine Nummer überträgt er doch immer mit. Die Nummer steht ja da.
Der Kongress hat eine Veranstaltung auch mit mehreren Veranstaltungen zu diesem Thema. Vergütung im Netz, Urheberrecht und Verfolgung von Urheberrecht. Dann werden wir auch einige Veranstaltungen und Workshops machen. Und noch viele andere Sachen. Und was genau, das erfahren wir dann alles morgen im Internet auf der Webseite vom Kongress. Näheres unter www.ccc.de und da dann gleich ganz oben. Der Kongress.
Der Kongress, haben wir noch was vergessen sonst?
Ich hab noch mal kurz sozusagen eine Frage an Markus, dass wir uns ein paar verweisesammeln. Es gibt ja auch Musiker, die sind ganz schlau und haben schon gemerkt, dass man dieses Internet wunderbar nutzen kann, um irgendwie bekannter zu werden. Und mittels freier Lizenzen, die haben wir ja auch schon vorgestellt vor der letzten Sendung, was das ist, dass man eben als Musiker sagt, ok, ihr dürft diesen Song zu nicht kommerziellen Zwecken bediebig kopieren, die sozusagen unter diesen freien Lizenzen auch ihre Musik im Netz publizieren und tauschen. Markus, hast du da irgendwelche Adressen oder Hinweise, wo und wie man im Internet so auf Musik von solchen Musikern stoßen kann?
Ja, da gibt's eine ganze Menge. Erstmal, ich hab einen Webblog, netzpolitik.org, wo ich...
Das bist du.
Das liebe ich so am Bloggen.
Ich schreib da auch manchmal.
Ich schreib da ziemlich viel zu dem Thema Musik im Netz und was es da gibt. Ein Beispiel ist zum Beispiel Brothers in Music. Das ist ein Berliner Live-Act oder verschiedene, die sich zum Live-Act zusammengeschlossen haben. Und die drehten hauptsächlich live auf. Und stellen ihre Mixe ins Internet unter freie Lizenzen. Und sie nutzen das halt sehr offensiv als Promotion-Material. Also Promotion-Weg, sie haben eine ganze Menge davon, wenn andere darauf aufmerksam werden auf ihre selbst erstellte Musik. Und sie buchen für Partys. Ja, auf jeden Fall ein sehr guter Weg. Dann gibt es halt eine ganze Menge Plattformen im Internet, die freie Musik anbieten. Zum Beispiel auf den Seiten von den creativecommons.org findet ihr eine ganze Menge Musik unter den Creative Commons Lizenzen. Dann gibt es eine ganze Menge Plattformen. Und ja, also man kann halt auch kostenlos Musik als Künstler bereitstellen und trotzdem davon profitieren, weil zum Beispiel Merchandising ist das große Ding. Also es gibt kleinere Bands und Labels, verdienen zwar nichts an, irgendwie Kaffeetassen mit ihrem Emblem drauf, aber die größeren schon. Und vor allen Dingen Live-Spielen bringt immer mehr Geld in Künstlers Kasse. Und dafür, für Live-Spielen, ist es immer ganz sinnvoll, wenn man irgendwie kostenlose Promotionen hat und Freunde untereinander Musik tauschen und weitergeben und auf neue Bands aufmerksam machen. Und ja, dieser Weg wird wahrscheinlich noch mehr bestritten werden.
Und die ganzen Verweise, die du auch eben gerade noch gebracht hast, finden sich entweder unter deinem Webblog, netzpolitik.org oder später noch auf der Seite von chaosradio.ccc.de werden wir dann noch mal zusammenstellen, auf was Volker gesagt hat und sozusagen seine Diskussionsgrundlage. Noch interessant wäre vielleicht noch mal, Markus, ein Blick auf die Aktivitäten im Bereich Urheberrecht oder alternativer Urheberrechtsvergütungssysteme, wer dort Kampagnen macht und die Politik gestaltet.
Wenn wir dazu noch Zeit hätten.
Die haben wir leider nicht mehr.
Dann sag ich noch zwei.
Zwei sagst du wie? Was sagst du zwei?
Zwei solche Entitäten, die was dazu sagen. Die Kampagne von der Grünen Jugend Copy4Freedom.de, Copy4Fredom.de. Ich glaube zur Europawahl haben die das gemacht. Wo es eben auch im weitesten Sinne um Urheberrecht und die Vergütung geht. Dann gab es noch ein bisschen was von Clubwasser, wo wir zum Musikboycott aufgerufen haben. Als die mit dem Klagewellen begonnen haben. Ja, das war es eigentlich auch.
Das war es eigentlich auch. Alles weitere nachzulesen auf chaosradio.ch oder netzpolitik.org. Das war Chaosradio 98. Vielen Dank Markus, vielen Dank Wetterfosch, vielen Dank Katharina. Katharina darf jetzt noch fünf Minuten lang Musik auflegen. Ich hatte eigentlich die Hoffnung, dass wir es schaffen, zehn Minuten früher fertig zu werden, um mir wenigstens noch zehn Minuten einzuräumen. Aber das habt ihr ja wieder versaut, ihr Schlote.
Liebe Grüße an meine Omi.
Die Musik im Hintergrund war live abgemischt. Nicht immer gut mitzukriegen, aber live abgemischt von Katharina. Und wenn ihr euch die mal live angucken wollt mit ihrem Projekt Studio 66, dann könnt ihr das tun. Und zwar am 15. Januar live in der Maria. Vielen Dank, dass ihr hier wart.